Дякую за перегляд!
Це страшно трохи.
Психіатрия, да, на самослову «психіатрия».
Зараз діагноземно хопаємся.
Да-да-да, там, знаєш, як медицинський справочник,
вообще нельзя відкривати.
Можна на себе все примерити.
і не тронусь то значить это нормально Настя ми всі з тобою ти ж знаєш могли би
помогати чемодан збирати зробили б це а так ми морально з тобою так що ти прям
маєш чувствувати нашу присутність а у нас завтра нікого ні в Одесі я буду завтра в Одесі
Денис, а чого ти Денису не сказала? Щоб виступила з одного. Спіли в супермаркеті, я помню, цей квест.
Тим більше, в тебе повинні завдання, Настя.
А коли в нас початок?
Ми просто чекаємо?
Кого ми чекаємо?
Чекаємо, щоб всі зібрались.
Ага, все, окей.
Дякую.
Доброго дня всім. Доброго дня. Ну я чекаю, поки мені дадуть відмашку. Не знаю, ми починаємо чи не починаємо.
Доброго дня.
Так, можемо починати.
Вже можемо починати? Ага, добре.
Так, які записи, якщо що, вони потім собі переглянуть.
Ага, чудово. Так, ну я б чув, про що ви говорили трошки, те, що зараз діанозі наставлюють.
Психіатр – це людина, яка може відрізнити справжній діаноз від несправжнього.
І тому, знаєте, коли пацієнт приходить і каже, ви зараз подумаєте, що я сама шерчую.
Якраз я не подумаю, якраз я точно скажу, я нічого не накручуся.
Мене звати Бережний Герман, я лікар-психіатр.
Сьогодні буду відповідати на ваші запитання після курсу Академії лікаря Ісаєвка в психіатрії.
Це був дуже важкий курс, насправді, він був дуже інтенсивний,
дуже багато важкого матеріалу, який, мені здається, неможливо розповісти
більш простою мовою, тому що це займе дуже багато часу.
Це не можна в такий кроткий період, це тільки потрібно рік-півтора розповідати
на дуже поступово. Тому, на жаль, я думаю, вам приходилось щось окремо догуглювати,
як іде чисто, штучний інтелект для того, щоб зрозуміти деякі речі.
Але все ж таки навіть студенти-мєдики, вони проходять цей курс за пів року.
Ви проходили близько трох місяців, це був в Академії лікарей Санко.
Я практикуючи лікар-психіатр, я маю досвід викладання в університеті медичному, психіатрії, психології, наркології.
Тому сьогодні я відповім про курс, відповім про психіатрію загалом, якщо є якісь питання.
про психологію знаєте більше за мене, про психіатрію, про наркологію, про медицину,
ну і може є особисті запитання, я також нам на них відповім.
У нас є приблизно дві години на все це спокоювання чудово.
Тому дуже важливо слухаю, які у вас є запитання.
Коли ви будете задавати запитання, то, будь ласка, скажіть трошки про себе коротко.
Якщо ви займаєтесь, де ви проживаєте, щоб трохи також розуміти контекст.
Ну що, ми стісняємося.
Я чув, там були якісь питання про дух.
Писали, я знаю, у чаті.
Хто задавав це питання?
Добрий день. Я так поняла, що я маю бути перш.
Я саме більше боялась, і я таки буду перша.
Щодо питань, от насправді, ясно, що інформації дуже багато.
Насправді, вона дуже така, ну якщо чесно, були моменти абсолютно відверто,
де я думала, що це тумач для мене, як для, власне, Аліна Велігіна,
психолог-консультант в інтегративному підході, коуч-менторка, власниця бізнеса,
і наставниця для жінок.
Ось, в даній академії я добираю і масштабуюся як спеціаліст,
ну, і як виявилось, і як особистість також.
Тут, типу, інакше не вийшово.
Саме про педавтику психіатрії, от прям я була щаслива почути,
що в нас вона тут буде, і тим більше лікаря Ісаїнка,
ну, це взагалі, це прям бонус, тому що я мала добирати.
Окремо. Коли я почала відкривати уроки і їх прослуховувати, я їх просто вже почала писати, скажу чесно, я їх всі не написала, і це точно, так як ви сказали, півтора роки буде на інтеграцію.
Я буду передивляти цей походу не один раз. Дещо думала про те, наскільки воно мені потрібне, наскільки я буду саме в своїй діяльності, воно буде мені корисне.
Чи я буду доторкатися до таких людей, чи такі люди будуть, клієнти, доторкатися до мене.
Але тут, напевно, всі зібрались, ті, хто страшно любить вчитися, і вчитися буде оцих два роки, плавно перетечуть в 25.
Багато для себе почерпнула, діагнозів собі наставила, єстіственно.
Щодо питань, рдух мене цікав... Власне, якщо говорити, ви сказали, що можна особисті,
Давайте будемо особистий кейс одразу людина з майже 10 років на антидепресантах третій вид були
була депресія післяродова депресія була генералізований тривожний розлад ставився МРО ставився
потім інший психіатр сказав, що немає, ну власне, в принципі, але я почала усвідомлювати, що я ближче себе почуваю
і поводжу саме до рдужного типу, і я хотіла побільше дізнатися, у нас тут, слава Богу, колеги вже більше почали транслювати
саме про поведінку і адаптацію людей, зердух.
І мені як спеціалісту було і є, і буде далі цікаво,
як працювати з такими людьми.
Як саме коригувати їх з прийняття, в першу чергу, себе,
навколишнього середовища.
Далі, ну ясно, що стосується саме медикаментів,
Я розумію, що мені потрібна по-любому буде консультація, можливо, і до вас я звернусь, щоб зійти з антидепресантів, бо це зараз у мене задача номер один.
І, можливо, підібрати просто щось інакше.
Але самоповедінково, тому що це ж все як то знеболююче, а в терапії ми вчимося жити.
Тому давайте тоді розкриємо, якщо можна, запитання про людей з РДУ. Дуже дякую вам.
Буду казати не дуже протокольно, просто про свій досвід роботи з розводом депіцитового гіперативності.
В принципі, що зараз відбувається, особливо, що відбувається в Україні з цим розводом.
Мої вчителі, старшого поколення психіатр, казали, що розводу депіцитового гіперативності немає.
Тобто це просто педагогічна проблема, що це потрібно працювати просто з дисципліною дитини.
Тому довгий час в нашій країні була гіпердіагностика, розвиток дефіцієнтової гіпердіагностики.
Тільки в разі, якщо це була вже така проблема, що дитина взагалі не могла вчитися.
Потім почався період гіпердіагностики, і мені здається, що кожен психіатр в нашій країні мав кейс і гіпердіагностіки, і гіпердіагностіки.
Десь він не поставив там, де треба поставити, а десь він поставив там, де не потрібно було поставити дефіцита уваги гіперактивності.
Чому проблема? Проблема в тому, що немає таких маркерів, як в інших захворювань.
Тобто, коли ви читаєте сімптоми РДУГу, ви бачите там себе, буду честен, я сам думав, що в мене якийсь період, коли я тільки починаю читатися, що в мене РДУГ, як всі знаєте, ви читали, думаю, та це ж
я, забув шавку у школі, та це я, йолкі палки, не можу почати якийсь проєкт, та це ж я, літери я, але там проблема в тому, що коли людину питаєш, чи забував профей, чи якісь речі, вона згадує всі свої
10 разів за все життя, водночасно думає, блін, так, так, забував,
Тобто, я не можу собі об'єктивно сказати, чи дійсно були такі випадки, чи ні, тому що це униклення спогадів.
Тобто, в один момент згадую всі ці моменти. Це було 356 разів на рік. Не пам'ятаємо цього.
Для того, щоб поставити діагноз, необхідно по протоколу дізнатися думка вчителя зі школи з приводу цього учня,
Наприклад, якщо це дитина, або якщо це доросла людина, то необхідно дізнатися якось, подивитися щоденник, як і зберігся, чи писала вчителька, що людина не дуже уважна, але має гарні оцінки.
Виробно поговорити з батьками, необхідно зрозуміти безпосередньо думку самої людини, провести бажано об'єктивне дослідження виконавчих функцій пам'яті, уваги, імпульсивності.
наприклад є такий тест МОКСО там де потрібно 15 хвилин робити монотонну нецікаву роботу клацвати
кнопочку от він також не досить об'єктивний але також він має місце бути або це дуже такі великі
опитувальники от і але ж також тут можуть бути проблеми запитуєш у батьків які працювали на
роботах в той момент чи був якийсь неструктіян або чи був дуже неуважна дитина була як всі діти
як всі діти хто б не знав потім якщо людина в цей момент останнім часом не зрозуміла що вона якась
неуважна то вона може собі також домалювати будуть ілюзії пам'яті де малює собі що так було багато разів
протягом життя і знову буде згадувати саме ті моменти коли вона була неуважна дуже довгий час
а ті моменти коли вона могла сфокусуватися вона просто забуде так також може бути і звичайно
тут проблема саме в тому що важко діагностувати і також те що інколи особливо вже в європейських
країнах там де є лікування психостимуляторами є також бажання людей отримати цей діагноз для
того щоб отримати рецепт на метілофінідат або афетаміноподібні препарати чому того що вони
допомагають усім краще навчатися навіть здоровій людини і багато студентів використовують метілофінідат
для того щоб вращити свої кредитивні навички для того щоб вращити отримати краще оцінку ну це такий
Грубо кажучи, так він працює, це правда.
Це такі складнощі.
Ще складнощі в тому, що всі критерії, які є і в міжнародній класифікації хвороб,
і в американській класифікації хвороб, вони також не дають повного розуміння,
тому що це питання про інтенсивність і про те, як довго це було.
Наприклад, дитині важко сидіти на одному місці і вона хоче встати і піти за заняття в школі, наприклад.
Я думаю, що у всіх було момент, коли хотілося встати і піти за заняття, правда ж?
Така система освіти була, або був такий вчитель, що щось їй не хотілося, або подружки ж дали за дверю.
Це такі критерії і від цього потрібно безплясати.
Тому це трошки важкувато в діагностиці, але все частіше ми починаємо краще розуміти,
особливо в Україні краще ставити цей діагноз, тому що в нас нарешті з'явилися ліки.
Тому що раніше ліків не було і особливо це питання не стояло, поставимо цей діагноз.
Зараз у нас з'явився атомоксітін, це такий не психостимулюючий препарат, який впливає на норадреналін, можливо, хтось чув про які антидепресанти, як дулоксітін, або вимлапоксін, вони впливають і на
серетанін, і на норадреналін, і також у нас в дуже маленькій кількості починається в державних аптеках метилфенідат.
Це препарати, які впливають саме на дофамін, тобто це психостимулятори,
такі схожі на ампітамін, на наркотики, такі речовини.
Ось, і що я хочу сказати, що насправді це захворювання,
перше, що потрібно задати питання людині, це коли це почалося.
Особливо людина, яка просто почитала, побачила тік-токи,
побачила десь в інтернеті, або почула про повзадебіцитова гіперактивності,
запитати, коли це почалося.
Вона каже, це почалося 5 років тому, 6 років тому.
Це значить, що це не рдух.
Чому? Тому що рдух – це органічне захворювання, вроджене,
яке проявляється до 12 років.
Тому це повинно бути все життя майже, снародження.
Чому це проявляється?
Тому що деякі ділянки мозку, які відповідають за увагу, за контроль імпульсів, розвиваються повільніше, ніж інші ділянки мозку.
І тому людина може бути з класним інтелектом, все буде чудово, але от саме тримати увагу і тримати свою поведінку вона не може.
Це генетичне обумовлене захворювання, 70% того, що це генетика, і що це було в багузі тусів, мову папу, менше проявляється, менше діагностується у дівчат, тому що дівчата частіше фенотипічно проявляю
ться без гіперактивності, а тільки з дефіцитом уваги.
І дівчата розвиваються трошки швидше, тому вони швидше встигають адаптуватися під соціум, як потрібно себе вести.
Тобто вони маскуються. Чи допомагають пігулки? Та, допомагають.
Чи це захворювання, розлад, це стає розладом тоді, коли людина повинна бути частиною соціуму.
Коли людина закінчила якийсь навчальний заклад, або просто навчилася в школі, їй потрібно працювати, а вона банально не може працювати, в неї не виходить.
В цей момент це стає для неї розвитком. Якщо ця людина працює, наприклад, якимось бізнесменом, і в неї завжди щось нове з'являється, то це стає навіть для неї трошки плюсом.
Тому що, коли швидко переключатися, потрібно між новими речами, без системи постійної, то це навіть може трошки допомагати.
Тому ми говоримо про розлад дефіциту ваги і гіперактивності як про нейровідмінність.
Чули вже про такий термін нейровідмінність? Це як один із варіантів норми, можна сказати.
Зараз до нейровідмінності відносять розлади особистості деякі, розлади дефіциту ваги і гіперактивності, розлади аутистичного спектру.
Тобто це інша людина, вона трошки по-іншому сприймає світ, і тільки коли більшість створює якісь умови, які підходять їм,
то ці люди не можуть відчувати себе комфортно у цих умовах, і вони тоді починають бути хворими.
І це, чесно кажучи, дуже таке питання дискусійне, тому що з однієї сторони людина може казати,
Мені не потрібна ніяка допомога, тому що я просто нейровідмінний і отстаньте від мене, а з другої сторони, це знімає стигматизацію.
Але з іншої сторони, якщо людинам із-за цього буде відмовлятися відплікування, це також не дуже добре.
Тому що, наприклад, дитинка може не розуміти ще 5-12 років, що з нею щось не так і що їй потрібно вивчити якусь інформацію,
вчитися рахувати, читати, писати, і тоді в неї будуть більш кращі результати по цьому життям.
Це з приводу медичного лікування, з приводу лікування психотерапевтичного,
я думаю, ви краще мене знаєте, про те, що існують деякі протоколи когнітивно-повідинкової терапії,
Це просто про те, як навчитися себе обманювати і навчитися робити собі якісь дофамінові виродження якесь за те, щоб закінчити якусь задачу, розбивати їх на маленькі частинки,
щоб робити собі нагадування для того, щоб виявити, які дистрактори будуть заважати виконувати задачі.
Тому що людині з розвитом рдуром важко, коли дуже багато інформаційного шуму навколо.
Тобто краще все очистити, щоб не було на що відволікатися.
Тоді буде набагато краще.
Тобто, да, це більше тренінг, навички.
Але, звичайно, трошки якісь нові нейрональні зв'язки можуть з'явитися.
але все ж таки цей мозок відрізняється від мозку нейротипової людини тому все ж таки нічого окрім
сильних психостимулуючих препаратів так же класно не допоможе на жаль от і ось так приблизно
ще які з приводу цього є до такої запитання дякую дуже ну класно розкрили ще маю кілька
запитань є такий міф не міф людина яка після кави лягає спати у неї немає рдух
немає рдух так якщо людина п'є каву типу вона її не бадірить значить у неї не рдух
Навпаки, навпаки. Дивіться, тут такий парадокс, ну не парадокс, а просто так звучить дивно трошки.
Є два неремедіатора, ви їх вивчали на академії, дафамін і норадреналін.
Ці два неремедіатори у нас дають, ну, щось про таке, не дошло так, як серотонін, сісти, сидіти і кайфувати в безпеці.
Це про якийсь рух. Нерадреналін — це бажання отримувати якісь досягнення, дофамін також — це винагородження за досягнення,
це про йти кудись, щось робити і так далі. І є таке відчуття, наче у людини з другом і так його, ну, дофіга, чесно кажуть, цього дофаміну, нерадреналіна.
Чому ми даємо препарати їм, які ще підбільшують?
Але тут виходить так, що різні ділянки мозку відповідають за різні,
може бути той же самий неремедіатор, дофамін, але різні ділянки мозку будуть виконувати різні функції.
І от саме в одній ділянці при фронтальній карі може бути мало дофамін,
і із-за цього контроль імпульсів зменшується і тому ми даємо дофамін людині з рухом для того щоб
вона навчилася це контролювати і от такий примір може вас коли когось з вас був досвід знайомих
далеких або незнайомих людей які приймали наркотики от люди які вживали кокаїн або вживали
амфітамін, наприклад, або MDMA, ну що, якісь такі психостимулятори, бачили десь відео якийсь.
Оце люди починають бути максимально сфокусувані.
Вони також ці препарати дають амфітамін і морадреналін.
Ось, і тому люди, які п'ють каву, воно дуже опосрєдовательно їх стимулює,
трошки виділяється дофамін в цій ділянці, і тому вона їх не бодярить,
а навпаки заспокоює і вирівнює, наче маленький амфітамін.
І тому ці люди дуже люблять каву, вони її п'ють, вона їх не бодярить, а заспокоює.
Правильно я зрозумів?
Може, я просто, чесно кажучи, не чую про те,
щоб людина, яка випавла каву, після цього пішла спати,
то в неї точно не нердух.
Так, принаймні, я неодноразово чула.
Окей, дякую, тут я зрозуміла, тепер у мене питання, коли, зараз, зараз би я записала і, я правильно зрозуміла, коли в людини, от давайте, це суто мій приклад, я відчуваю максимально, да, от, ідей 100
мільйонів, потенціал просто пре віздє, осісти і зробити, ну, тобто це тупо себе і знасилувати,
що при цьому робити потрібно втрачати потрібно ну типу медикаменти
уже приймати так чи це можливо все ж таки з допомогою терапії з цим справитись
от називалось тільки реалій все-таки мені здається що ви щось могли сісти і зробити
Ну щось робиться але це правда дуже важко Ну це прямо через да я розумію що це окей що вам
напомагається зробити дедлайн напомагає дедлайн однозначно але не хочеться відкладати просто тих
хвистів так багато що це вводить в стрес в тривожний далі назад стан да і то є мене опять
починається все назад по колу. Так, розуміє. Ось тут різниця дуже важлива між ртух і, звичайно,
людина нормативовою. Те, що дедлайни не мотивують. Виникає тривожність, але людина це не може в університеті завжди.
У мене був практицій приклад. Жінка, яка чотири рази її відраховувала з університету і вона
відраховувалася з найвищими балами. Вона поступала в один і той же університет, знову і знову, повторювала,
повторювала, але вона не могла написати оцю роботу дипломну в кінці, просто тому що інтелект
був супер, все класно, але не мала себе зробити. Не могла себе змусити сісти і навіть подолом після того не змала зробити.
Я перепрошую, зараз, я говорю вам про зараз, що я це роблю, але що стосується там юності,
все-таки там раніше, то точно, ну мене відчислили саме по тій причині, в мене високі оцінки,
але мені тупо я не йшла на пари. От я не можу себе заставити, я вивчу домашнє,
все класно, все супер, ну типу от оце встати, прийти і розказати.
Тобто ми адаптуємося в будь-якому випадку, виходить. Це говорить про адаптацію.
Це говорить про те, що все ж таки рдух — це дитяче захворювання, і більшість, половина майже людей адаптується до рдуху у дорослому віці.
Якщо казати про статистику, воно десь там до 7% зниці у дітей і 2,5% дорослі люди населення можуть мати ще проблеми з дефіцитуванням гіперактивністю.
Інший момент. Часто є інша сторона роду, це гіперфіксація.
Тобто це також не як такий бонус, це також проблема з регулюванням,
тільки тут не на тому, щоб сфокусуватися, а на тому, щоб розфокусуватися.
І часто люди з РДУГом ловять гіперфікс на чомусь дуже легкому,
дуже такому дофаміновому, якась гра, проєкт, щось нове, аналізна дуже сильна.
І тут також потрібно зрозуміти, це дуже важливо для діагностики,
настільки це просто фіксація, страсть, фіксація, настільки це гіперфікс.
Якщо провести відміну від норму типового людиною і другого, то гіперфіксація — це втрата розуміння часу.
Я думаю, багато в кого було, коли людина щось робила класне, грала, серіал, вночі, ще одну серію, ще одну серію, ще одну серію.
або там інші речі робила, але якщо цю людину, наприклад, звичайно покликати, то вона може сказати «ну час, час, іще чуть-чуть, іще чуть-чуть,
або там проінорувати, намагатися щось відповісти, але при цьому, ну так, бути ще фіксовані в цьому, але якось реагувати на зовнішні подразники.
то людина з гіперфіксації ну вона нічого буквально не не чує тобто люди які живуть з людьми з синдромом
дефіцитового гіперактивності вони знають що потрібно підійти отак от просто так повернути в глаза
зрительний контакт отримати і сказати я тут приходи в себе нам нужно виходити через 10 минут
і ця людина ще може себе десь хвилин після цього відчувати на чому тільки прокинулося після гіперфіксації
тобто от вона там не знаю грала кмітерну гру 6 годин і після цього наче встала і відчуття наче вона
не розуміє де в нас знаходиться таке як після пробудження от це от обратно все равно це не
класно ну як те які випадки звичайно це може бути класно якщо це щось що там приносить гроші
і далі так би якийсь розвиток якщо це фіксація на чому що не дуже корисне скажімо так то це також
проблема в тому в регулюванні своєї ваги там ми не можемо сфокусуватися тут ми не можемо
розфокусуватися Ну і звичайно ми тут не говоримо вже про гіперактивність і імпульсивність як такі
додаткові в нас ще є речі може бути така класифікація ордух виключно дефіцитували є ордух
гіперактивність і імпульсивність і комбінований тому це взагалі дуже важко дитинка з гіперактивністю
з імпульсильністю, це може під кольосами машини пробіжати, все що угодно.
Подумав і вже зробив, і це може бути дуже погані моменти.
Знаєте, поки Юрій йде по вулиці і хоче познайомити з дівчиною,
10 хвилин має чи підійти, чи познайомити, чи ні, то людина з цією проактивністю вже як знайомиться.
Тобто і не зрозуміло, чим це все закінчилося.
І можливо цією людиною навіть є дружина, але він вже знайомився, це не дуже добре.
Можна я з вашого, перепрошую, будь ласка, саме з того останнього, що ви сказали про гіперфікс.
Ну от, наприклад, ясно, що якщо я, наприклад, створюю авторську, господі, карти метафоричні, і я гіперфікс, все, це мені на розвиток, це мені все класно, не можу доробити, ну, дедлайн, ладно, він мен
і допоможе доробити.
Але коли є якийсь, як ви кажете, гіперфіксація на чомусь некорисному, непотрібному тобі,
тобто в тебе є якісь базові, грубо кажучи, обов'язки, а в тебе гіперфікс просто в одній точці,
як можна допомогти людині саме розфокусуватись фактично, або хоча б могти переключатись?
Потрібні завнішні якісь символи.
Наприклад, уходить людина і каже, я там завесла на одному і все просто капіт, що мені робити?
Наприклад, зазімлення, якесь, але потрібен якийсь, як условний рефлекс, потрібно виробити людині.
Я зараз так трошки отдалі скажу.
Є таке захворювання деменції різних видів. Коли людина забуває все, якщо це якась органічна деменція, у вас там було закон РІБО,
коли людина забуває все від нещодавних спогадів, повертаючись назад поступово до дитинства, людина в 75 років може думати, що її 12.
Тому що вона забула все, що було після 12. Як наростали розпомінання, так в такому порядку, обрати мені і згасли.
І людина, звичайно, не може запам'ятати в новій квартирі, тому що вона не пам'ятає, що вона тут жила.
І не отримує нових ніяких збогадів. Вона вже не може навчатися, які дині навички вже впали.
Вона не може запам'ятати, де знаходиться в неї. Там річка сварить, де посуд і так далі.
Вона буде завжди потірена, вона буде не матися піти додому.
Але якщо їй це зробити дуже багато разів поспіль,
вона навіть не пам'ятаючи, взагалі не розуміючи,
де знаходиться це все рефлекторно, без кори головного мозку,
якщо відчуває голод, рука автоматично тягнеться в ніжний ящик.
Там завжди, що це бить.
Тобто це як собачка павла, грубо кажучи.
і от можна виробити такі от умовні рефлекси наприклад на якийсь на якісь на вібрацію на браслеті
якщо я там відчуваю вібрацію на браслеті необхідно встати що-то там подумати я нахожусь осознати
вистрінка там посмиріть вагу спомніть що не нужно лібо відкрити своє записник де написані мої справи
тобто от і це виробно робити дуже багато разів це працює навіть у вісні тобто людина це зможе
зробити тому що це навіть вісні працює чули колись про чи ви чули колись про свідомі сновидіння
це коли людина розуміє що вона знаходиться в вісні вона можна літати кувиркатися
тобто людина в цей момент трошки покидається але спить свідомість приходить вісні і є така
практика як це можна навчитися потрібно виробити якийсь умовний рефлекс в житті для того
в вісні це повторить наприклад коли людина бачить грубо кажучи світлофор кожного разу дивитися на
годинник отак робити постійно протягом багатьох багатьох місяців грубо кажучи і чому саме
годинник тому що годинник у вісні відображається не так як в житті там цифри не можуть у вісні
відображатися буде він якійсь деформований циферблат якщо це отакий механічний годинник
І отак от людина буде йти, дивитися, о, світлофор, стою на світлофорі, подивився на годинник.
І так одного разу, як у мене був такий дозвіл, я подивився на годинник, колиша в університет,
подивився на годинник, а там на цифлю 2 петля додаткова.
Тобто я зрозумів тоді, що ага, все, це я обіснюв зараз, це не посправжено.
Це я вам кажу про те, як працюють ці умовні рефлекси у людей, яких взагалі майже немає кари головного мозку,
дуже нейродегенерація пішла людина в несвідомості коли вона спить да і це може бути в людини за
другом також да тобто дуже жорсткий такий рефлекс от це може заставити людина оце зробити на який
звук як є там знаєте це принцип помідору датам дзвоночок зазвіняв дзвіняв все варібно зреагувати
щоб аж знаєте щоб аж мурашки пішли якісь потім і так людина ввімкнулася це буде важко да але це практика
Але я ж не психотерапевт. Ви, мабуть, краще мене знаєте.
Можна дати йому просто метілфінідарно. Це мій підхід такий. В мене все просто.
Дякую.
Так, добре. Дякую за спитання. Так, Марія, я казав. Марія, я підняла руку.
Вітаю. Приймаю дуже познайомлю. Десь мене звати Маша Граф, я менторка-коуч, працюю з жінками.
І у мене таке питання. Зараз дуже багато ми говоримо про ПТСР, і у нас дуже малесенький урок там був, тільки на 11 хвилин чи щось таке, і хотілося б від вас більш детально, тому що, по-перше, ми всі
з ПТСР можемо зустрітися, які зараз щось побачите, щось цей.
В мене, наприклад, чоловік після поранення зараз проходить реабілітацію, теж зіштовхнулася з цим. До мене приходять жінки, дружини, яких чоловіки повертаються з ПТСРом. І ще чула, бо я дуже глибоко н
иряю сюди, про те, що, наприклад, зараз все може бути окей, а потім через 8 років, через 10 якийсь тригер і буде ПТСР.
Чи це правда і як працювати нам, допомагаючим професіям, до мене приходить жінка, вона без ПТСР, але в неї є чоловік і вона хоче якось, як з такими людьми працювати і які особливості, може, з вашого
досвіду було б дуже цінно? Дякую.
Ну тут важливо розрізняти ПТСР, в першу чергу, і розлад адаптації.
В чому різниця? Є в залежності від трігера.
Тобто є трігер, це звільнення з роботи.
Хтось з людей скаже, капець, все життя хотів працювати на цій роботі,
мене звільнили, ужас, і у людини йде дезадаптація,
людина знаходиться в такому пригінченому емоційному стані і так далі.
Когось звільнили, він сказав, що все, клас, наконєць.
І пішли ви всі трамати тебе, я нісі не хотілося.
І вільно гуляє, і все чудово.
Тобто цей трігер може викликати різну реакцію різних людей.
При посттравматичному стресовому розгляді повинен бути такий трігер,
який викличе однакову реакцію у всіх людей існуючих.
Тобто це смерті, це пошкодження, це може бути навіть не безпосереднє,
якби переживання травми,
а якщо людина розповідає близько про якусь травму,
це якісь стихійні, якісь лиха,
це війна, звичайно, це злахування і так далі.
Ось, що потрібно розуміти про це захворювання,
про посттравматичне?
Це те, що людина не може переробити свої спогади
і як інші звичайні люди.
Тому що це подія, ну я їх так трошки
образно розповім.
От, ви всі чули таку фразу
«Утро, вечером, утрині».
От, вечером ви думаєте, що все,
з мене хвати, там,
я тебе ухожу,
я бросаю цю работу, я не хочу
этим займатися, я решила,
я решила, все, я більше всего не хочу.
Утром в раці прокидаєтесь і думаєте,
да, в принципі, ну, все не так вже плохо,
ну, нормально, вже трошки емоції спали,
вже коли людина поспала, є відчуття, наче це вже було якось давно,
і є відчуття, наче вже не так актуально, актуальність зустрічається.
Людина з посттравматичним стресовим розводом,
для неї навіть та подія, яка відбулася вісім років тому,
може бути відчуття, наче це відбулося пів години тому.
Тому що оцей сон, він не допомагає втратити актуальність і яскравість цієї події.
Тому найголовніше, як і розлад, відбувається при посттравматичному розладі,
симптом найголовніше, це проблеми зі сном.
Людина не може нормально поспати і не може нормально перекинути
із кроткострокової пам'яті в довгострокову подію.
Тому що для нас одна із теорій, чому нам дарібан сон, це для того, що в фазі швидкого сну, коли у нас очі так вдохаються,
фаза називається Rapid Eye Movement, швидкого вручень, в цей момент людина якраз і переработує інформацію,
і скороткостраховує, і довгостроковує, де ще потрібно. І воно стає, вже тачає актуальність.
А цей спогазь, він такий товстий, що він не пролазить цю вірочку, щоб вправити туди, в довгосрочну пам'ять.
І він постійно тусується, оце наче тільки що це відбулося.
І от тому людина і не може через довгий час, не може вона адаптуватися.
І це от, я не знаю, можливо у вас було таке, з врахуванням, хто знаходиться в Україні,
що там вибухнуло щось, і потім після того вибухнуло ще 3-4 дні, ви ще дергайтесь.
А потім пройшло і деякий час вибухів не було і все, трошки вже нервова система успокоїлася, це вже відійшло на задній плані.
Потім знову вибухнула і знову вибухнулася.
А тут людина буде дергатися постійно. Тобто наче це відбулося тільки що нещодавно.
Погано спить, флешбеки, повернення. Реакція сильна на якийсь рефлекс чи треохолу, коли дуже сильно реагує на якісь незначні трігери і дуже яскраві повторення сновидіння.
Там є кілька видів того, вона може бути вмикаюча, ця поведінка, або напоки якась емоційна реагуюча і так далі.
Що потрібно робити? У мене підхід звичайно з моєї сторони, як я це роблю, це назначить призначити лікування,
прибрати симптоми, трапити психотерапевту. Я розумію, що хотілася б дізнатися якийсь такий класний лайфхак,
що потрібно саме так себе вести з людиною з посттравматичним стресом.
Ну, на жаль, тут є набір правил, але це трошки не моя специфіка, щоб про це знати, на жаль.
Звичайно, я знаю, підходи психотерапії, це травмофокусована терапія,
це десенсибілізація руху мочей, якраз щоб імітувати цей сон швидкий.
Людина рухає очима, проговорює травмуючу ситуацію і таким чином трошки зменшує
сенсибілізацію від травуючої цієї події.
А так ми призначаємо антидепресанти, снодійні препарати для того, щоб ти наймало краще спати і все це перепрожити.
І, звичайно, просто банальна сіль, будемо бути обережно.
Тобто зрозуміти, які теми вона хоче підіймати, яка не хоче підіймати.
тому що може бути такий підхід, як звичайний людина, ти виговарився і ті речі стані, ну просто банально.
А в цьому випадку, ну, коли людина виговарюється, вона стає ще більш агресивною, більш злою, вона знову це перепроживає,
і це не працює, тому просто не потрібно чомусь стимулювати, просто як хочеш, так і роби, як тобі комфортніше.
Тобто це перше. По-друге, потрібно не відноситись до цього з,
Ну, з шутками. Так буває інколи, що над деякими психічними захворюваннями можна трошки підпочутіти і це, навіть класно, для людей з психічним захворюванням вони трошки зменшують рівень напруженості і
драматизації свого захворювання.
Наприклад, тривожні люди, вони приходять і валять тебе, здрасьте, є тривожний кабанчик.
«Адавайте, що це діла?»
Тобто, це вже якийсь такий, ну, вони з цього трошки шутять, і це нормально.
То люди з ПТСРом, ну, і вони не розуміють з цього, це їм буде зараз і невесело.
Ну, ось, якось так.
Тобто, звичайно, це потрібна бути парна терапія, це повинен бути спеціалізований військовий психолог, який в цьому розуміється.
якщо це в сім'ї, ніж жінці, то їй потрібно пройти спеціалізований тренінг.
Я зараз не можу сказати, який саме, чесно кажучи, я тут не знаю.
Моя задача більше знати про захворювання і призначити лікування.
Тому я тут в деяких випадках, можливо, не зможу повністю повісти на ваше запитання,
в повній мірі, як ви хотіли.
Ось так.
Дуже дякую, дуже дякую. Взяла для себе, дуже багато дякую.
Дякую за запитання.
Так, а мистецтві.
в психіатрию села займатися,
ну, тут...
Там доведу, там уберу,
уже привыкла, да, с этим,
как-то бизнес построила, кстати, Анастасія,
30 лет предприниматель,
коуч-ментор, вот.
И вот
как-то страшновато.
Ну, опять же, у меня высокая тревожность,
я с детства грызу ногти, у меня постоянно дергається
нога, ну, так, вот себя.
Вот, ну, і страшно при этом,
а що буде? Какі є побачки
з цих препаратів.
Якщо ми говоримо про спецілостимулятори, то там побачки
вообще дуже неспецифічні, такі, дуже обші, так, це в начале
особи на терапії. Слабость, усталость головная, біль,
раздраженность, нічого такого, що могло напугати, скажімо так.
Якщо ми говоримо про метилфенедат непосередньо, таку таблетку,
спецілостимулятор, класичний. Якщо ми говоримо про препарат
атомоксетин, який може бути в каждій аптекі в Україні,
по рецепту естественно то там есть адаптация двух-трех недель например может быть сонливость
наоборот может быть холодно ознобу может быть гиарея может быть яркие сновидения могут быть
пробуждение ночью может быть расширение зрачков усиление тревожности но снова таки ничего такого
что могло бы очень сильно навредить и нужно всегда помнить что эти препараты назначаются деткам шести
за руль, можна садиться, да, с этими препаратами.
Звучитка ситуация. Внимание.
В любом случае, даже если начинаете принимать препарат вначале, иначе она, наоборот, делает хуже,
то вы поймете, то есть, как в обычной жизни, вот у вас все неплохой день, и вы понимаете,
і голова болить, і не виспались.
Ви понимаєте, що за руль садиться сьогодні якось не сильно хочеться.
Тобто ви в себе не поверені.
Та же саме з таблетками.
Якщо ви будете не поверені, то ви не сядете.
Ви почувствуєте, що не хочеться садитися.
Це не алкоголь, який здає відчування, що все отлично, я все можу.
Це вже йде помрачення сознання.
Чоловік вже не зовсім віддає, що у нього критика падає в цьому состоянию.
Ви використовування технікаторів критика не падає.
Ви себе чувствуєте так же саме,
Тільки немножко поменяються емоції,
І, можливо, як раз буде положительний эффект,
Улучшиться концентрація внимания,
Улучшиться контроль.
Ну, вот, если говорить про деток,
То некоторые родители против,
Потому что дети становятся лучше учиться,
Начинают, они становятся более послушными,
При этом родители описываются у детей,
Как будто они стали более роботизованными.
Емоціональні такі, ну і сподівники.
І тому родітелю це тежло дивитися.
А якщо, ну, не поверен, наскільки це правильно-неправильно, це випадково відповідно.
Але зі сторони взрослого, якщо це допомогає, то, звісно, люди приймають і в житті відбувається.
Але знову ж таки.
І якщо ти почав їх приймати, то це все вже на весь останок, да?
не лечиться таблетками, то есть здесь именно в этом случае, да, пока месь ви пьете, уходят симптомы, вы не пьете, уходят симптомы, можно провести параллель с аллергией, например, да, вот весенним пан
енозом каким-то, вы можете проходить с сопликами всю весну и лето, да,
Либо ви можете пропити антигистамин і не чувствувати цього.
Але вони не влечуть нічого, вони просто беруть симптоматику.
І воно просто...
Там є хочао якой-то шанс.
Там є уколи, які там коляться 18 місяців.
Так, це вже другое підходку до терапії.
Такой я б хотівла раз і навсегда. Раз, пропил курс і все.
Нет, це вже таке устройство мозга.
Я ж СВГ-шник, я ж можу забыти випити.
А так оно і відбувається, тому що в начальні, коли це нове, інтересне,
Оно пьється, а потім через некоторе время, через три місяці вже забувається,
тому що становиться битом і вже теряється дофаминне підкріплення.
Уже не так возбуждает ця історія, не так интересно.
Ось так, с таблетками. Благодарю.
Ну, в общем, да, ще туди-сюди.
І вторий вопрос. У мене лично теж така ситуація проїшла,
що ми були в Харкові перві три роки, полномасштабного,
і після цього рішили виїхати на три місяці віддохнути в Іспанію з ребенком.
Младше в 10 лет вернулись, і у нього почалися навязчі звуки.
Так поставила нам Лора, а потом к психіатру пошли, сказали,
чи таблетки, чи вивозити. Попробуйте пока вивезти.
Вивезти з этой. То есть мы вернулись, і вот это ПТРСР начался.
Я приняла рішення, що таблетки, я ж тоже не очень такая.
Думаю, попробую вивезти. Мы вивезли, у нього щас спокійне вистояние.
І ось тепер питання, коли вважається, може ли це повернути?
І вже все, це вждуло в ту дырочку, в ту дальнюю пам'ять?
Не, якраз воно, якщо... А, да, все так правильно.
Скажіть, навязчиві звуки, що мається віду?
Він почав хрюкати.
Це все було непризвольно.
Глаз подергивав і хрюкати.
Прямо, ну, як хрюкати.
Я понял.
це бути кастикозної рості кики, бакальні кики?
Це кліні кики, це були прям звуки, його не переклинивало, його не дергало, нет,
він просто якісь звуки міжду делом просто издавав.
Ну, це бакальний, тобто звук.
Непроизвольно, це вообще ніякого нету.
Да, да.
І цього не було раніше, що це не було.
Вот именно, коли ми в'їхали в 10, 9 йому було тоді.
Началося в 6.
Началося в 9.
9 йому 10, да, ми більше років вже в'їхали в Болгарі живемо.
Але ми в'їхали, пока ми були в цій ситуації, да, під Харком, то все було нормально.
Але коли ми в'їхали на три місяці в Іспанію, віддіхнули, перезагрузились, вернулись, у нього почалося вот це.
Як тільки ми виїхали в Болгарі, тут у нього теж була адаптация, страхи, ужасно. Психологом займалися, я сидела там під школою. Ну, то есть, це було прям панично. Такий, ось, все, нікуди не відходи,
все. Все це прошло, адаптировався за три місяця, їх нет. Мы приїжджали на неделю там дому і уїжджали. Ну, да, у нього з'являється страшно, але спокійно.
І, якщо так повернутися, це може бути...
Ось зараз він планирує на три місяці приїхати.
І може ли повернутися це, чи це вже туди вшло?
Може, да?
Ми не можемо сказати точно, в який момент це пройдуть.
Але я можу сказати точно, що це пройдуть.
Це возрастна історія, і часто в анамнезі остається,
коли в взрослому возрасте це більше проявлення.
Якщо це стресове, то це точно проявляється, це не ПТСР, то есть ПТСР не проявляється локальною медикою. Це просто мононевроз у ребёнка, мононевроз проявляється одним симптомом.
Діти нейропластичны, у них дуже быстро появляться нові нейронні связи, разрываются старі, добавляться нові, і тому вони перерастають.
І, в принципі, це стимулирується, цимулирується антидепресантом теж, тому що влияне на серотонинові рецепторы, вони запускають каскад химічних реакцій, які розвертують ДНК, і починається синтез BDNR,
мазового нейротрагічного фактора, який, в конечному втогу, усиливає якраз цей нейропластичність, появляться нові зв'язки.
Тобто так чоловік може переучитися, бояться темноти, то у дітей так, естественно, процес так само самостійно і відбувається у дітей.
Тому це чисто детська історія, я не знаю, вернеться ли це в цей раз, але я знаю, що точно, що це нескільки років постепенно-постепенно вгаснє.
Тобто не може бути тако, що це буде не просто в один момент, а це буде відникати два рази в місяць, потім ще реже, потім тільки після стріса якогось.
Іспугався перед екзаменом, появилось на некоторое время, на неделю прошло, ну, це таке може бути. А потім вообще може бути ректуральностю.
Да, але з'явилися, тут поработав психологами, адаптация прошла, все, і тепер я буквально недавно услышала, він ночі скрипит зубами, і він стал грызть ногти. Це повод идти опять к психіатру.
Як це вважає?
Є люди, які вважають половину ногтівопластин.
Вже без ногтівопластин входит.
Тому що вони вдирають.
Одно зубами – це бруксизм.
Тоже може бути от разных.
Стоить для...
Ну, як минимум, наверное, що-то легеньке,
успокоїтельне, може даже травяне.
Магні.
флора какая-то да то есть возможно что-то простенькое ну а если ребёнку это мешает он прям сам не мешает он же зубы стирает я по нему просто самой бруксизм это ну не забывайте про генетику если у вас
такое было похоже у меня такое есть понятно это ещё генетически проявляется конечно в большинствах есть заболеваний генетическая предрасположенность
Прекрасно.
Принимала антидепресант, а наутро випила антидепресант, а вечером рожала.
Вот не настільки безопасно.
У психіатров, у них завжди багато спектр чого безопасного, а не другого.
Це їх основной інструмент, і це безопасно.
Нам, з іншої сторони, каже, по-другому.
Тому прийшли, спрашиваю, наскільки безопасно.
А що опасно?
Жить опасно, я розуміюю.
Я розуміюю. У життя є побачний эффект смерти.
Але я имею в виду, що ці препарати, які назначаються зараз, люди потім не хочуть їх отменять не тому, що вони стали завісеними, а просто не чувствують себе на них намного краще.
і якщо чоловіку не подобається препарат, то він просто мені не подобається, нікого не погоджує.
Тому я розумію, що за цей граню рецепт, аптека, препарат, який потрібно пить дуже довго,
несколько місяців, годів і так далі, які впливають на мозг,
але це якби значально вже звучить дуже неприємно, також опасно.
Но на самом деле за цими чотирами знаходиться препарат,
который совершенно безвредний.
І у кожного постсоветського чоловіка є таке впечатление, це нормально.
Не, тут главное донести своєму клієнту, який приходит, що це нормально.
І тут вже сказав, ну, тому що дуже багато, я не ісключення,
і дуже багато, які, ну, так, я нормально.
Ні один алкоголик не з'яснюється, що він алкоголик.
Ні один, ні один кричащий там, що-то у нього не так, тож не зазнається.
І коли приходять, дійсно це видиш і підсвечиваєш, що тут хочеться донести, що не все опасно.
І що є дійсно.
Я якраз привожу пример от того, що існується антидепресантами.
Ну, ви, наверное, маєшлися сертралин, той же саме, статалопрофантантники, два самопопулярних антидепресантів,
Которі можна дітям в шести лет розрішити.
Которі можна при кормлінні груджі молоком.
Которі можна при беременністі і вовремя родів.
Ніка не влияють на плод.
С котрими можна, іноді, навіть, навіть, алкоголь.
І які, ну, взагалі, навіть не влияють на життя.
Которі можна, в принципі, в будь-який момент збросити.
Тобто, якщо чоловік не подобається, він просто їх проставить.
Ну, і ще сертралин немножко уменьшає аппетит і масу тела.
Девчі одразу з цього кажуть «хочу», назначайте, а там вже не має значення, які тежі побочні ефекти, просто назначайте.
Ну, не завжди, конечно, але це побочні ефекти.
Хороші побочні ефекти, благодаря.
Так, Юрий, будь ласка.
Здравствуйте, Герман. Меня Юрий зовсім. Я детектив, такий образ взяв, не коуч.
Я задам вопрос, з точки зрения більше клієнта, а не своїх інтерпретаций, добре?
Звісно.
У чоловіка є тревожно-депресивний розлад і сильні симптоми,
такі як плаксивоск, тело ломить, як при кріпатурі,
желання збавитися від цього стаєння, і зжження в груди.
І як в першій неділю антидепресантів можна мотивувати,
щоб якось восстановити желання щось робити,
тому що він плачет, тревожиться і так далі.
І ті триггери, т.е. зі з-за якого наступило це стане, він в них живет і не має можливості від них відбавитися.
Так. Можна задати пару уточняющих питань по поводу клієнта?
Я зараз покажу діферційна діагностіка, яку проводить психіатр для того, щоб поставити правильний діагноз.
Тривожно-депрессивне расстройство – це діагноз дуже, скажімо, такий лінивий, тривожно-депрессивне расстройство.
Почему? Потому що тривога – це вона, коли людина все боїться, депресія – коли людина хоче умереть.
То є це противоположне состояние. При тривогі людина боїться умереть, при депресії людина хоче умереть.
Тривожно-депресивне растрійство, ось таке странно звучить.
Тому там, скорее, є депресія ізначальна, з таким ажикированням, з компонентом,
коли чоловік ще у нього внутрішньо возбуждений.
Либо це така уже тяжелая тревога,
яка вже істощила чоловіка, і він вже просто немає силу бороться з цим.
Тобто це вже депресивний компонент добавляється.
Тобто що-то було ізначальне.
Скільки року пацієнту?
Около сорока.
Около 40 роки. Мужчина, жінчина?
Жінчина.
Коли це у її було з подросткового возраста, або це відбувається недавно?
Це перший раз.
Перший раз. В подростковому возрасте якісь проявлялися необычні?
Нет.
Тобто ми виключаємо різні виробні, або різні спектру. Це якщо називалося психопатії, а зараз це називається різність. Наприклад, пограничне різність, антисоціальне, тривожне різність. Це теж частина
характера чоловіка. Хорошо. Цього не було. Некоторе час. Це відбувалось недавно. 40 років.
Хочуть менше, десь 38-39 роки відпочивалося.
Що стало причиной відпочивання?
Тобто ми маємо розуміти, що це відпочивалося зі внешнього стимула,
або це просто внезапно відпочивалося в голові.
Це відпочивається ендогенна відпочивається.
Лічна життя, назовемо це так.
Парфінгу.
А, значить, є людина, який не може бути ряду, бути з цим чоловіком по яким-то своїм причинам, да?
Угу.
Але приходиться вместе работать, наприклад, да, і постоянно видіти цього чоловіка.
Ну, грубо говоря, да.
І з-за цього відбувається відчування жження, якісь мурашки, слези, плаксивість і так далі, правильно?
Угу, де-то так.
Ми, це, цей клієнт во рівня розговору,
Слишком емоціональний?
Я б не сказав, що слишком емоціональний.
В цьому нормально, але буває емоціональний теж.
Наприклад, дівчина, яка...
Ну, вот зараз дівчина включається, задавали питання,
вони говорили так, ну, обичним тоном.
А є люди, які розмовляють «вот так», вони емоціонують, вони можуть заплакати, а потім засмеяться через 5 секунд.
Є такий спектр емоцій у цього чоловіка?
Ні, вона нормально розмовляє, просто є моменти, коли емоції можуть, як сказати, вийти наружу дуже сильно.
Я розумію, якісь точки триггерні в діалогі. Це у мене, со багато я можу з чоловіком з чоловіком спілкуватися, і розумію, що якщо я сюди нажму, то будуть слізи.
Але в цьому багато є якийсь мій інтерпретаж, т.е. я багато людей зчитываю болевих точок, але в цьому взагалі не той адекватний, просто вижу, що є болеві точки, а сюди якщо нажати, то пройдуть слези,
грубо кажучи.
Т.е. емоціональної лоббічності немає? Перепаду настроєння просто безключно? Бустро, вовремя разговору немає?
Вовремя разговору немає, плюс-мінус, нормально.
Я зараз виключив істеричне різництво річність, т.е. це люди, які демонстративно-показательні, і для них дуже важливі внимание, коли вони теряють
какой-то відвідування, то у них часто проявляється жжучки-калючки по телу проходять, т.е. був такий симптом, ми це виключили.
Хорошо. Плаксивость, жжене, як со сном, з аппетитом?
Со сном, з аппетитом?
Через раз?
Скільки це всього дліться по времені?
Ну, вот, першу неделю на антипресантах.
До цього була теж попытка, коли прямо було плохо, а в цілому дліться десь 1,5 місяця.
А це це все 1,5 місяця? Тобто, це така острая реакція?
Тобто, не 2 роки дліться?
Ну іменно це глибоке створення, якщо було.
Харше.
Тобто, що це діагноз буде називатися
«острій реакції на стрес».
Якщо це щось різке відбувається.
Человек не може відбутися з цього.
Либо це соматоформне, соматизованне расстройство.
Коли психічне, емоційне, проявляється
в виде телесних змінів.
Наприклад, рження в руді.
Це соматизованне расстройство.
Такий питання. Вопрос в тому, як прожити антидепресант в першій неділю?
Да, як це легше з цим справитися і прожити це все.
А які є симптоми на антидепресантах?
Якщо відказалися, що відбували на антидепресантах?
Ви вже неправильно зрозуміли?
Це жження в руді, це з-за антидепресантів?
І було до антидепресантів?
Ні, це не їздив, це було і до.
Ага, так.
Так, а що зараз мешається чоловіку непосередньо?
Ну, дуже погано в цьому в цьому.
Типа, нічого не хочеться, плачуть, тревожиться.
Як допомогти дожити, коли міський препарат заработає, так?
Угу, так-то так, наверно.
Ну і смотри, який антидепресант.
Ви знаєте, який сертралин із этого прамбарксетину?
Заворти?
Не знаєте?
Щас прокручую.
Не, не знаю.
Ну, смотри, є некої антидепресанты,
Котори, які викликають дуже сильну реакцію вначале, ухудшують состояние намного пациента.
І він має бути об цьому підрючений.
Особенно, якщо чоловік тривожний, напряжений, звинчений, як оголений нерв.
В цей момент він максимально уязвим.
І коли чоловік починає приймати антипересанты, і він вже і так боїться цих симптомів,
то вначале парадокс такий, що це все усиливається.
Тобто, коли вважається...
Його підтримували, але йому все одно тяжело справляться.
Тобто потрібно справляться.
Тоді потрібно попросити доктора, который без антидепресантів,
получить прикрютие, так називаємо.
Є препарати, які не лечат,
але вони позволять допомогти тут і зараз, в моменті.
Це не група антидепресантів, це група, звісно, транквилизаторів
і анксіолитика.
Существують препарати під названням,
наприклад, всім известний, гидазепам.
Существують гидроксізин,
он же атеракс. Существують прегабалин.
Существують флюангсол
і т.д. і т.п.
Вони, по-голосі, і сейчас.
Покам'ять заработає антидепресант.
Тому що ми не ускоримо процес
і не зможемо уменьшити симптоми.
Тому що це тільки, к сожалению,
діло времени.
Тобто це в 2-3 тижні можна бути.
Ана аторакс п'є, але приступи все одно є.
Увеличити дозу аторакса, замінити аторакс.
Какою дозу аторакса п'є? 25 мг?
Написано чи не написано?
Іщу, да.
25.
Аторакс можна п'євати, наприклад, до 4.
Але, опять же, я не можу зараз не п'єдя пацієнта і лечити.
Це я так розмішляю, не прийдуть к дійсню.
Тобто, якщо не допомагається, і зараз дуже важливо,
то тоді либо влічується доза до максимально робочої, допустимої,
либо меняється препарат.
Наприклад, гидозепан на новості неї атеракції.
При гавалині по-другому дійснює, ніж атеракцію.
Є антидепресанты, які можуть заработати, в принципі, і быстрі,
Але вони мають свої побачні ефекти, наприклад, всім известний амитептилин, але у них є свої особливості, тобто, в принципі, якщо чоловіку дуже тяжело, не потрапляється з цим, не потрібно терпеть,
потрібно знову обращаться і попросити якийсь комплекс прикрытия.
А як мені з нею взаємодействувати, як я можу її як чоловік підтримувати? Не як психіатр, як як чоловік?
Так, як чоловік, ну, вперше, розслітрати ці симптоми, як щось, ну, наприклад, у мене є жіння в телі, що це жіння, наскільки це жіння сильно бажається, тому що вона його боїться, наскільки вона дійсно
невыносима, може вона більше на ньому фіксується, а з-за цього вона усілюється це жіння, і вона дуже сильно переживається за нього, і може, і потрібно брати актуальність,
Дивільність цього Жені в її житті, не обращайте на нього увагу, подумайте, що другое, переключитесь, тому що постійно скринних і фіксация своєго тела, вона усіливає відчування.
Либо, якщо она його боїться, наприклад, то спрашивайте, а к чому це Женя може привести, по її мнению? К чому? К інфаркту, к інсульту, к тому, що вона загориться і загорит.
Тобто, яким моментом? Довести, наприклад, до конца, його страху. Іспользувати якісь допомоги, тут вже знаєте мене намного, які є способи отвлечення, релакси, способи заземлення, дыхательні техніки, а
утогипноз, медитання і такі остальні речі.
Тобто це все працює.
А вона вона вона вона поможете, а вона не поможете?
Вона вона поможете в любому влечі.
Тобто з першими симптомами від антидепресантів з побочним эффектом,
наприклад, наприклад, з невротичним розвитком, якою обратилась ваше клієнтко,
Либо усиление препаратов для того, чтобы убрать эти симптомы, либо максимально попробуйте перетерпеть эти симптомы, как их можно перетерпеть, отвлечься от них, посмотреть в другую сторону, не думайте
об этом.
це завжди працює.
Звідти працювати, пройти прогулятися,
посміряти фільм, знайти щось хобби,
ввідти щось інтересне, це, звісно, працює.
А якщо наоборот брати і розбирати цю тему,
або це не найкращий час?
Це краще ставити після, як вона подійсує?
А розбирати цю тему непосередньо болезненну,
яка стала причиною?
Дайте їй 3 недели на адаптацию к препарату, і потім она буде готова, заживит цю рамку.
Для антидепресанту она заживит, і чувствительність уменьшиться.
Час наоборот, якщо її розковыряли перше.
Представьте, основне действо антидепресанта – це повищення серотонина.
Серотонин – це тормозащий нерамедиатор,
Деремедиатор, который потормозит весь мозг и особенно негативные эмоции.
Да, і вони становятся такі більш отдалені.
Вот якщо хтось відпочивається паническу атаку, там, який знає, з знакомого і так далі,
то вот люди описують на антидепрессантах в первое время,
що паническая атака, як будто тревога, она как будто появляется внутри,
но вот она где-то дуже глубоко, да, то есть она как будто ее за яким-то большим слоем чего-то накрыли.
Слоем серотонина, грубо говоря, да.
Но в начале приема серотонин наоборот уменьшається, наоборот, чувствительность увеличивается всього, наоборот, хочеться, становиться більше, да.
И поэтому я говорю, що в первые 2-3 недели вообще беріть еболичний, включайте Netflix, смотрите, що угодно, відлетайтеся, займайте своїми делами, буде неприятно.
Но потім буде, це того стоить, скажімо так.
Але це не завжди, є інші антиаписантки, які побачення не викликають.
Такі, ну, вони індивідуально. Кому-то менше, кому-то більше.
Біли случаи, коли взагалі нічого.
Але імено в вашому випадку, так, звісно, отрісться, перетерпеть і зараз не нагружати.
Зараз чоловік більш вязвимий, ніж обычно.
А через три тижні можна все вже починати копати.
Короче, краще його куда-то ввести, какую-то роботу, хобби, що-то ще, щоб просто туди не дивитися.
Ну да, це як варіант.
Але зараз не в полной боєвої готовності, щоб третитися з цими триганами. Не зараз.
Нет, просто, знаєте, у нас учили роботи з цілом. Типу, що для тебе говорить ось ціло «боль в груди»?
Ну, в такому форматі, щоб це обсуждати, щоб дати цьому час і місто. Назовемо це так.
Вопрос актуальності хочеться чоловік об цьому говорити.
Я думаю, що якщо вона прийшла за цим, щоб висказатися і розповідати про це все, і це сталося чіт-чуть легше,
ну, тоді не мешайте їй в цьому, не треба її відводити. Якщо стимулюєте її це робити, а вона це робить через болі, тоді краще не треба.
Короче, дивитися у моменті, на скільки в моменті, по реакції, вименьшається чи увеличується?
Якщо увеличується, то не йти, якщо уменьшається, то йти.
А в целом уводити в якісь інші області, щоб препарат підійшовував, правильно?
Ну можна, в принципі, якби спросити.
Ви хочете, або ви зараз не сильно готові до данного моменту?
Либо хочете подожити.
Або, можливо, зараз так, настільки тошно і плохо від всього?
Тому що тошно, в прямому смыслі, тошнота возникає в першому часі.
І чоловік дійсно мов. Тільки зараз говорить о високому не хочеться.
Банально спрашивайте, ви щас готові об цьому говорити?
Либо подождем, поки нічого регулирується. Оно срегулирується.
Радний рік.
Приняв. Більшого.
Спасибо за питання.
Так. Елена. Добрий день.
Добрый вечер, да.
Мене звати Елена, я масажист, я лечебні масажі роблю, коуч-ментор, той, хто ми щас проходимо, понятна.
І я акушерка по образованию, коли ми проходили психіатрию, конечно, але це було давно, я вже нічого не помню.
І у мене щас приходять мамы, у котрих маленькі діти, 5-6 лет, і у них повищений тонус, гипертонус мышечний.
Його діти дуже активно, він коли научився ходити, ходив на пальчиках, то есть все ці симптоми гипертонуса. Я ж не можу сказати, що йдіть сразу відправитися в психотерапевту. І діагноз я не можу
поставити.
Вони спрашиваю, масажем це можна влечити, ну, обрати гипертонус? Я показую, як робити цей массаж, тому що робіт не лежить на столі, він як уж на сковородку йерзає. Я їм показую, вони уходять, вони
розуміють, що це безполезно.
От який я можу ще совет дати в своїх рамках? Без діагнозів, без нічого.
Вони дуже часто кажуть, ми п'єм магний. П'ять ночі спить, потім опять все проявляється.
А це в якому місті?
Берлін. Ну, зараз Берлін.
А, я просто думав.
Відходять наші українці.
А, тобто, які теж дітки, які застали боєві дійства, да?
Ну, нет, нет.
Ага. Ну, по поводу носочков, гипертонус, это ж ще симптом у нас, может быть, расстройство аутистического спектра, когда не ходить на аутистического.
А, аутистического.
Да, да, иногда может быть. Ну, тут понятно, що це не единственный симптом, це цей комплекс, це одно із проявлений, може бути.
То есть там один вопрос, но в основном родители должны замечать первые там три года в жизни ребёнка, а если гипертонус, ну я примерно понимаю, о чём вы говорите, я могу вам перерассказать то, что я
говорю иногда своим пациентам, да, возможно, вы используете это в своей практике, потому что, ну, бывает, присылают, знаете, другие специалисты, те же самые массажисты,
Другі ерготерапевти і так далі. І вони приходять, люди такі, я не знаю, що я тут сделаю, мене вже відправили, ну я вже прийшов к вам, тушу, конечно, раз уж прийшов, ну скажіть. У мене просто напряжен
і мышці і все, а так я людина полностью адекватна. В чому вопрос?
Так вот, напряження межць – це один із чотирьох симптомів тревожного расстройства, такий із основних напряження межць.
Почему? Потому что происходит такой вот у нас цикл гипофизарно-гипоталамо-гипофизарно-надпочечниковая система. В гипофиз поступає какой-то импульс, который пугает человека. Точнее там медалевидное
тело, медалевидное уже направляет это все в гипофиз, гипоталамос там обрабатывается, отправляется в надпочечники.
На почечниках у нас находяться гормони, кортизол, адреналин, норадреналин, он выделяється в кровь, і йдет напряження всіх мышц, тому що це механізм, як у їжика, який сворачивається кружочок, шарик і
випускає іголочки.
Тільки у нього це більше, краще роботає, ніж у нас, тому що у нього ще нападення, защіта і нападення, то у нас мисці напрягаються для того, щоб защитити наші внутрішні органі в клубі опасності.
Тобто це такий механізм, то есть грудні мисці напрягаються, мисці спинні і так далі, щоб вдруг нас буде хищник кусати, для того, щоб ми могли отразити цю атаку.
Тобто це основна причина, що можуть напрягатися мышці, з-за повшеного стресу. Магний в основному действует периферически, то есть магний в основному действует на нервные окончания, вот он расставляє
мышцы, то есть непосредственно точечно действует.
Але нам необхідно брати першу причину, снизити вліяние на медалевідне теле і далі на гипоталаму гипоталаму на кульчинкову ось.
Коли ми беремо першу причину, в конце розслабляється тело.
То есть, да, вот так ісходить.
Якщо ми можемо зробити, грубо кажучи, це мануально, напрягти в одну місць в місці сильно, потім це буде гиперрасслаблення.
Але це буде добре, перші нескільки дні, потім він знову напрямокся.
Діло там, що там все тело напрямлено у ребенка.
Тому що можна нажати, щоб де-то розслабило вас.
Ну, звичайно, ну, объясніть, що здесь, ну, масаж – це добре, естественно. Масаж ніколи не буває трішній. Масаж – це все добре.
Але якщо така тежува запущена історія, то об'язнити цей механізм «почим це напряження»?
Нужно розуміти, що напряжен не тому, що він замерз, або в залі перекачався,
а тому що він постійно чувствує, як будто він знаходиться в пещере з волками.
І ось він готовиться, що волк буде кусати.
Тому він напрягся, щоб йому, звісно, йти, сердце не вирвали.
Тому він напрягся, повністю, защитив себе з усіх сторон.
Тобто це так працює.
Я приводив на такий дуже грубий пример.
Один, хтось коли-то був чи рос бабушек в селі, і ми такі були.
І є такий працює, що свиню потрібно різати швидко.
Ізвиніть, це такий пример, тому що, якщо вона успеє відпугаться,
то мясо буде неприводним котріблением.
Тому її добре в серці ножом, либо молоточком по голові бьют.
Мало буде жоскою, да, да, да.
Мало буде жоскою.
Чому? Картизол і адреналин выделяється в міжці.
І все, воно вже там не розслабиться.
І от, извините, але, наприклад, то же саме відбувається з людьми.
Тобто, відбувається і наше сталоо становиться жоским.
Получається, що к індокринологу бажаємо, щоб просто пошла мама з дівчинком?
Чого к індокринологу?
Із-за того, що гипофіза, гипоталамус – це не те.
Не, не, здесь нейро-індокринологічний момент.
Т.е. індокринологія работает нормально.
А вот іннервация этой індокринологічній системи нарушається.
Так буває часто нейро-індокринологічній момент.
У дівчині проблеми задержки менструатуи длительні. І тут гінекологу говорять, що тут зниженний гормон, там естроген, тут проблем, повышенний тестостерон і так далі. І спрашиваю, що робити? І гормони
пить, що робити? Говорят, а нічого, по ендокринології все нормально, треба убрать стимуляцію мозга на цю систему, на яичниці, і тогда це все виробняється.
То есть, да, вот эта система, адреналіологічка, она работает хорошо, но управление її работает плохо.
Я поняла, спасибо большое.
Спасибо за вопрос.
Так, Юлия.
Здравствуйте.
Я предприниматель, учусь сейчас здесь, в академії, вже заканчиваю на коуча.
Я дуже давно увлекаюсь психологією і в продуктах Светланы Ісайенко вже ще до війни.
Наверное, лет 5.
Лабораторії щастливих людей, книги. Нравится мені ця тема.
Значить, перший вопрос. Я хочу продовжити.
Алина там вначале говорила за антидепресанты.
Це лична моя тема теж.
Звісно, в чому? Можна ли с них сойти после длительного прийома, щоб не возвращаться туди більше?
Скажу, як у мене було, значить, перший раз я їх почала приймати, це було до війни.
Я так понимаю, у мене це як послеродового було. Діагностіровано було теж тревожно-генералізованне різництво.
Я приймала год, а потом я прекратила принимати, ну, согласовано с доктором, все хорошо. Год я, все было нормально, и потом опять ко мне вернулась тревога, очень сильная тревога. И вот это уже сейчас
пошел третий год, опять, как я их принимаю.
Ну, пока тревог то нет, но пока я не готова их оставить.
І мене як-то, знаєте, німножко стремновато.
Стремновато, що вернётся це стане, це раз.
І вторе, це...
Якщо так втягнула, у мене все вбежали мисли.
А що вернётся стане, і вторе, що буває така я нестабильна, емоціонально.
Тоже, як Алина говорила,
«Сложно себе що-то заставити,
у тебе багато идей, у тебе багато планов,
а тебе, я думаю,
що без антидепресантов
що могло б бути ще хуже».
Вот який момент.
Я то функціоную, я за це время
развиваю бізнес, учусь,
воспитываю дітей,
займаюся спортом, жить йдет.
Но я понимаю прекрасно,
що оно могло б бути зовсім інакше,
Якщо б це було без цих тормозів, коли тобі сложно себе прям витягнути, оторвати від кровати, щоб пройти і почати все-таки що-то робити.
Ось так вот.
Це талопранка?
Ні, сертралин.
Сертралин?
Да.
Тут просто часто стоить вопрос в тому, какой це антирепресант, от седативного до активіруючого.
Ну вот сертралин один із самих активирующих, поэтому, наверное, уже выжать більше с активаций не получится.
Либо добавлять щось. Я понимаю, що це медикаментозний. Більший у вас вопрос в тому, как можна ли вообще без них.
Теоретически антидепрессант назначається для того, щоб человек пропил його вначале полгода-год, второй раз полгода-год, если нужно буде.
і теоретически він вийшов з цього свого тревожного
зустрічого зустрічого відповідь, що можна
жити по-другому.
Тобто, коли ви наводились без антидепресантів,
ви поважаєтеся до своєму опыту антидепресанту і думаєте,
ну я ж на антидепресанта по-другому реагував.
В принципі, я попробую зараз вернуться в це
зустрічого зустрічого і поріагувати так.
Тобто, обучиться, научитися.
КПТ, научитися по-другому.
Тобто, якщо брати протокол і тревожне раційство, то в середньому тревожне раційство длится у чоловіка в острої фазі генералізовано тревожне раційство 10 років.
Несмотря на то, приймають чоловіка антидепресантів, або не приймають.
Тобто, це ніяк не наявляє.
Тобто, антидепресант в основному просто обирає симптоми.
Будем честні.
Есть вероятность, крайне маленькая, ввести в ремиссию человека, но после інтепрессанта ремиссия крайне коротенькая. То есть это может быть пару месяцев, например, к сожалению, ремиссия. Может быть и
годы. Это может быть тоже.
Я апеллирую внимателемо даними. Возможно, да, то есть это все какая-то вероятность. То есть, если ответить четко на ваш вопрос, можно ли быть без антиперсантів? Конечно, можно. Но это нужно не просто
испытывать тревогу на фоне, а нужно уметь с ней работать.
І для цього, тому в цьому світі перша лінія терапії – це психотерапія. Іменно ліпокаріна піднійська терапія, ліпокаріна піднійська терапія, ліпокаріна піднійська терапія піднійська, це другое підход.
І к цьому всім, наприклад, КПТ – це научиться її убирати вну тревожність, а терапія піднійська відповідь відповідь – це сусуществувати з нею, за нею наблюдаю, жити з нею, але при цьому не сильно від
її страдати від тревожності.
Ана є зараз, ну, хороше, пусть живе.
Т.е. як-то так.
Зараз, по статистике, 30% населения землі,
у когось такий период времени, страдав таким видом тревожного расстройства.
Т.е. даже ведуться к дискуссії о том, является ли это патологией,
либо является это одно из вариантов норм,
потому що тревога – це же нормальна, в принципі.
Тому що саме смелі умерли ще в какой-то виниковій період,
коли вони не зберігалися, то вони вже самі смілили, від нас залишли, залишились більш тревожні люди.
І просто питання в тому, що сріда зараз така, коли ми знаємо більше, чим нам потрібно знати,
і волнуємося о більших вищах, які ми повинні волнуватися.
Тому це стимулює час тревожних людей на те, щоб чувствувати дискомфорт дуже серйозним.
І також це можуть бути кіто обостріння після якихось стресових збрілибо просто рецідив якийсь. І буває таке, що людина все одно теряє контроль і вже не може сам себе допомогти, і навіть психотерапев
ти вже не може.
Вот тогда коротким курсом пропивати антидепресант, для того, щоб дати себе почву.
Коли почва з'являється, треба працювати з тревогою, треба працюватися.
Либо, якщо людина, будь честні, неспособна психотерапію.
Возьмемо с якимось бабуску 75 років і скажемо, давайте на КПТ.
Которая ніколи, але вона боється умереть від онкології, або ще щось, така вона виглядає інкофобія.
Ну, звісно, їй проще вже назначить препарат, щоб вона його приймала, тому що не буде вникати, що таке тривога.
Вона навіть не може задаватися вопросом, що таке тривожність.
Але якщо чоловік має достаточний уровень інтелекта, якщо він современий, розуміється проблеми і хочеться жити,
то, звісно, це годи і годи терапії, тренингов.
Тому психіатри в цьому випадку – це скорая допомога.
Ми це стабилизуємо чоловіка.
Научити жити з цим, научитися справлятися в дальнішем – це вже здача ваше.
Каждає в своєй степені.
Тобто і психотерапівтів, і психологів, і массажистів в тому числе.
Тому що чисто в конькенопоєнській терапії прописано таке упражнення, як прогрессируюча миорелаксанція, по-моєму так, розуміється.
Це коли напрямаємо якісь мышці, розслабляємо, тіло розслабляється і параллельно розслабляється у нас мозк, тому що її така обратна связь, да, воно считає.
Или с диханням. Тело дышит медленно, мозг считывает это, і понимає, що тело не беспокоїться,
поэтому ми тут можем розслабитися в голові. Тобто це все дуже важливо.
Вопрос в том, наскільки це виходить. Якщо не виходить, то лучше не ухудшати і ухудшати
бесконечнество і качество життя, тому що людина не виходить з дому, а все-таки пить, а не депресант,
якщо альтернатива немає. Якщо альтернатива виходить, то лучше займатися самообразованням,
сихотерапії.
Тому, якщо у вас є желання,
антитерапії мають багато своїх негативних
послідствів, і вліяние на гибидо,
і відстанливість, і проблеми з аппетитом
некоторих людей в різні сторони.
І, звісно, не хотілося б.
Тому, якщо є желання,
і ви піли год-полтора-два,
в середньому вчитається год – це оптимальна.
Така, я так німножко уточню,
а какой смысл їх
прекращать, якщо ви говорите, що тревожне
растрійство, оно по-любому буде
около 10 лет.
То пробьєшся год, ну, типа год
пропиття, а потім що? І опять
через три місяці опять начинай пить?
Есть ли смысл тогда вообще бросати,
щоб пару місяців без них пожити?
Інтенсивність меняється.
Тобто він може з'явити інтенсивність.
Вот, яком антидепресант.
В ремісію
він чуть-чуть може ввести,
скажімо так, в некоторое время.
Це відповідальність маленька, к сожалению.
Вот я по своєму опіту скажу. Відповідальність маленька.
То есть я чуть-чуть сам себе вправлю. Вероятність того, що це буде не 10 років, а 3 роки є, але така маленька, що я особо на нього вже, ну, лично я вже особо увагу не обращаю на це.
Ми даємо спробувати перший раз человеку садисантидепресанта, второй раз садисантидепресанта, може быть, помогло, третій раз вже в протоколі прописано, назначається на усмотрення врача на такий срок.
Пять лет, десять лет і так далі.
Ну все равно ми перше время шанс даємо, що вдруг вважається длительну реміссю,
тому що, ну, в случае є, коли людина 25 пропил антидепресант і потім вважається 50.
Зачем мені мені вже було пить від 25 до 50. Правильно, мені ж був.
Вдруг не треба.
Тому все це дуже індивідуально і якось таке прям правило якого-то особи нету.
Ну, я, например, я говорю, что если, например, вы снова почувствуете,
что вам нужно будет попробовать антидепрессант,
ну, снова будет рецидив тревожностей,
сначала попробуйте подходить на КПТ.
Если не поможет, то да, снова антидепрессант.
Угу. Не, я КПТ уже сейчас прохожу.
О, супер.
Заработаю, да.
Так, у меня есть еще, уже не по мне, а, значит, второй.
Это по шизофрении.
Інтересно було, коли я там смотрела уроки, і я пыталася його відлічити от...
Так, що там за діагноз цей?
Биполярного расстройства?
Да, от биполярного расстройства, коли людина в манії.
Так.
Получається, і там є дезорганізація, і там дезорганізація, і там галлюцінації, і там галлюцінації.
як ви розвичаєте це, якось можна, ось таке відвичай, у нас там екзамінаціонна робота,
ну, там вже як-то сложилась картина, розумієш, що це, але я думаю, що я там
немножко запуталась. Я думаю, що в ній шизофрінія. Разниця.
Зараз там сказали, що вона вже більше місяця, і вона ухудшення. Типа, десь біполярно біжитло біполярно.
Смірте, біполярно і шизофрінія. В чому разниця? В біполярному різнімі обязательно зміна цікла, фази.
то есть депрессивна, або маниакальна. Между этими фазами человек возвращается в полную норму,
вот вообще как будто нічого не було, і он, це все, що відбувало в фазі манії, фазі депресії,
он чітко осознає, і он чітко комментирує, що це було вообще капец, я не розуміло, що відбувається,
у мене було щучнення, якщо чоловік знаходиться, яка я розказував свій опыту.
Вовремя шизофрії у чоловіків у чоловіків повністю мається його лічності,
і він вже більше і більше буде теряти свою критику к цьому станію.
І навіть якщо він вийде з цього стаєння, острою стаєння зійдет,
але все одно буде продовжуватися какое-то изменення.
Навіть якщо спросити чоловік, а чому ти себе так ввел, наприклад, думав, з кем-то разговаривав.
Ну, не показалось, це був нервний срых чи ще щось.
Тобто буде це диссимулировати, заглажувати, рационалізувати, розвіцять і так далі.
Тобто, в цьому плані биполярне расстройство, в ньому більш благоприятний прогноз.
Тобто, чоловік в промежутках между фазами живет полноценно жизнью.
І так буде до конца життя, буде жити полноценно життя.
І якщо вберете таблетками фазу, і вберете от реміси,
то при жезофренії з кожного приступу буде хуже, хуже, хуже,
і, в конце концов, в пожилому возрасту, він вже буде інвалідом, к сожалению.
Тобто це все більше і більше дезеронізація.
З кожного приступу буде все хуже і хуже.
Симптоматика манії і жесофрения дійсно може бути схожі, але найважливий компонент – це при манії стойко повышенне настроєння.
Тобто може бути повышенне не тільки, що він всіх любить, радується і т.д.
Ну, може, їх не є, але чоловік ускорений, т.е. чоловік ось такий, там все бістро, т.е. така триада маніакальна – це ускорение мышлений, ускорение движений і патологічне повышенне настроєння.
Т.е. в начале, действительно, якщо вийти перспацієнта, ну, можна перепутати, тому що чоловік в психозі, коли думає, що за ним сидять всі служби мир одновременно, він тож може бути швиденький, такий
спішить в цей момент.
Але, тим не мене,
якщо в динаміки наблюдається,
то він в който момент успокоїться.
Він перейдеться в состояние...
Буде подозрительний, але тихий.
То ці люди не успокаиваються в манії.
Вони постійно бістри, бістри, бістри, бістри.
Вплоть до того, що у них даже починається хрип в хорле.
Падає голос.
Тому що вони постійно розмовляють, розмовляють.
Уже не можуть вже зупиниться.
У них, якщо вони багато кофі випили.
Такі, бістрі, це основне.
При цьому в них можуть бути галлюцінації,
але вони часто спровождаються,
именно, соответствують настроєння.
І тому що в приманії чаще всего бредової идеї галлюцінації,
галлюцінації такі редко, в приманії чаще бредової идеї геніальності,
ізобретателністі, чого-то такого плюс,
такого великого, прекрасного, грандиозності.
«Я придумав новий бізнес», «Я придумав новий вид сигарет», «Я хочу построить подземний город, какой-то огромный под Києвом», «Я знаю, как закончить войну, я еду к Зеленському для того, чтобы его
сейчас остановити і рассказати, що він не догадався».
Ось такі, якщо чоловік що-то знав невероятно, і він в це свято верить, і він весь такий на енергії.
Тобто, якщо прийшатися в рівні, то там більше такі параноїдні симптоми.
Такі, наприклад, я узнал какой-то там секретний заговор, і тепер я ставлюся частю цього заговору.
Я там... Некоторі речі почав видіти по-другому, тепер я осознал, що це все були знаки і символи.
т.е. він може, може бути тихий. Необязательно ця скорість, ну в цьому разі. І там і там ця організація мишлень, це правда.
Але вот от цього триаду маніакальна, вона відвичає. Ускорене мишлень, повищене настроєння.
Второй момент. Родственники больних на шизофренію.
Щас сполкнулася у знакомых, познакомилась с дівшкою, у нього мама больна, і вот, що родственники страдають від цього,
коли людина відказується,
у нього нет критики к состоянию,
і вона говорить, що я здорова,
що ви все ко мене лізете з тими таблетками.
І вона говорить, що перестала пити таблетки,
і вона ухудшується, вже не следить за собою.
Тобто, вона прогресує.
І в Єрміні теж, вона говорить,
що в больниці її не забирають.
І що людям делать, родственникам?
Ще второй случай у мене зараз. Девушка, я вела п'ять сесій,
она ко мне пришла на последнюю сесію, попросила поговорити о сістрі.
Я не психолог, но у нього чувство вини, поработати з її чувством вини.
За що вона переживає? За то, що у сістрі теж шизофрения,
і то, що вона її там к себе забрала.
Вона убіжала от нього. Це 40 років вже.
Она убежала, і она її подавала там, искала через поліцію,
нашли її через нескільки місяців,
але сказали, що вона не хоче з вами говорити і зустрічатися,
і ми не можемо сказати, навіть, де вона.
І вот людина мучиться, що не може знайти свою сестру, як, з нею, що.
А їм, виходить, що в цьому вироках було,
що в них пропадає ця зв'язку з близькими, емоціональна зв'язка,
їм все ровно становиться на чувства близьких.
Як ви підтримуєте близьких?
що ви їм які рекомендації дайте.
І в першому світі, коли людина відказується,
і вони з ним живуть, і їм як-то потрібно...
Ну, і живуть з ним, і вони там одна живуть.
І забрати к себе не можуть.
А коли діти в цьому растуть?
Така швидка.
Тут появилась дуже необычна проблема,
яка возникла в воєнний період,
з іміграцією особливо.
То, що менталітет на самом деле влияє на то, як буде протекати шизофріні, чісно кажучи.
Тобто, звісно, схожі симптоми, але менталітет влияє.
Тому що люди в Україні, вони мене довіряють іншим людям, якщо так сложить.
Тобто, якщо ми ненашко так, спочатку не довіряємо, а потім довіряємо.
То люди непосередньо там в Європі, вони більше довіряють, скажімо, саму государство,
вони більше довіряють своїм врачам і так далі і тому подобне.
І тому там чіт-чуть другої системи здравоохранення.
Тобто там є, наприклад, правила відкритих дверей в психіатрію.
Тобто, чоловік почувається, якщо він, наприклад, сильно опасний,
то його стабилизують в 2 неділи, а потім він може ухати кудово.
В будь-який момент, тому що считається, що цього достатньо,
Человек послушається просто за своєю внутрішнього стержням, і це правда так. Психіатри, які працюють, наші працюють, в Германії, наприклад, отмечаю, що по-другому себе ведуть люди в психозах.
Але інший момент, коли психіатри європейські лечат нашого брата, вони їм довіряють, але ми ж не довіряємо, але наші пациенти не довіряють.
Тобто були, к сожалению, такі случаи, що отец по всій Європі ездив з цього репенка лавил,
якому 20 років, у нього був дебют психічного тяжелого заболівання, то в Нідерландах, то в Германію, то в Польщі,
везде він поліжав, в каждій країні по 2 недію, його просто випускали, давали таблетки мужу в руки,
і він просто брав, садився в поїзд, їхав куда-то, у його немає тормозів, він їхав куда угодно.
Тому то, що працює в Україні, не працює в Європі, к сожалению.
Як-то так так сложилось історически.
І якщо б ви задали, що ці люди живуть в Україні...
Вони зараз її відправляють в Україну, там її мусь, вона з дітьми була.
Ну і вон там як-то ще будуть продовжувати лічення,
Наверно, обращаться к психіатру.
Да.
Якщо...
А не в Харпері.
В Харпері, да.
Третья областна психіатрічна, 15-ка, да,
Взывається у нас.
Якщо...
У нас, скажімо так, дадуть такий укол,
При якому не потрібно пить таблетки.
Человек, він буде в течение місяця работать,
І спеціально цей уколи розробляли для тих людей, які не хочуть приймати таблетки.
І тому це їй поможуть.
Кололи і тут такий, я не знаю, чому перестали.
Кололи, і ще плюс к нему давали таблетки, які татану обриснули.
Перестали.
Вот вони чуть-чуть, скажі так, для них стабилизувати не так важливо, як не навредити.
Тобто вони не будуть рисковати, європейці.
В цій проблемі я замечаю в єрпейських врачах.
Тобто вони краще знімуть від себе відповідальність і не будуть давати те, що можливо дасть набор маси тела,
або теоретично незначительний, але не самый приєдний ровчий ефект,
але зато чоловік вийде з цього, вони краще не будуть різковати.
Тобто вони дадуть в меру того, щоб не перегрузити, грубо кажучи, по чуть-чуть давати.
Що можеш сказати родственникам?
В першу чергу, объяснить, щас конкретно по вашому кейсу, щас я уточню еще,
но вообще, що ми говоримо від родственників, це в першу чергу, то, що часто від родственників нічого не зависить.
То есть, вони починають рационалізувати, починають пытатися знайти причину,
почему он як-то так думає, ну, тому що це близький чоловік, і хочеться объяснить,
Почему он що-то злій, почему він тут злій,
почему він тут не так себе ведет.
Бежала, почему, да, як вона говорить,
почему она бежала?
Да, почему бежала?
Почему вони пытаються додумати
і знайти в себе причину.
А я себе зробив щось по-другому.
Да, да, вот с цими работаю.
Особенно, це якщо діти і родити,
то родители пытаються постійно щось об'яснювати.
Але тут це не працює.
То є, це буквально всплеск нейромедиаторів.
може произойти все, що угодно,
совершенно все, що угодно.
І, взагалі, це ніяк не зв'язано
с внешними стимулами.
Совершенні. Як би себе чоловік не ввел,
що б він не ввел, як би він не ввел,
як би він не ввел, як би він не ввеликий підход.
Але якщо його переклинило, що,
наприклад, йому вгрожає какая-то опасності.
Але все, що угодно можна робити,
чоловік все одно
буде виспитувати страх.
Але я можу привести вам примерку кейса.
є, ну, там, обычна семія, ну, хорошее семя, достаточно, да, там, мама, папа, ребенок.
Ребенку там було 19 років, в момент, коли у нього був дебют.
Учился в университете, в высшого образовання учав.
І в один момент, хто-то скинув там із групи, в университете, ну, поток, там, большой чат, в Телеграмі, Виконтакте, тогда ще був.
Сбросили ссылку какую-то на контент неприємливого содержання.
Да, це детская порнографія, скажімо так.
Кто-то сбросив на це.
Ну, і там спроводив, типа, зайдіть, там, це там, у барі домашнє задання.
Ну, так, короче, рішили пошути якого-то дурного чувства юмора.
Пацієнт зашел по этой ссылці, в цей момент он це увидел случайно.
Це стало триггером, який запустило заболівання.
Але при цьому йому могли наступити на ногу в трамвай, це все одно було трігером для запуску, т.е. не важливо, що там могло произойти, а що запустять, і воно у нього було заложене просто именно таке,
може б, воно позже розвивось б, а може б, і не розвивось б, тож вероятно, ми тут, к сожалению, тож не знаємо, це генетически обусловлене заболевання с внешним яким-то запуском, і у нього ломається л
огика в цьому моменту.
Тобто, якщо я це ввідділ, рівно я педофіл. Тобто, як у нього зробило. Тобто, я ввідділ, я педофіл. Ну, баякно, що педофіл – це не той, хто случайно ввідділ, але йому це вже не ввідділ. Дальше у нього
працює логика. Якщо я педофіл, значить я должен бути наказан чим-то. Он вбиває, як наказують педофіла? Педофіла наказують химіческой кастрацією. Ага, химіческая кастрацією.
Значить, це значить, що це вещество має бути, що я потребую, має підсыпати.
Він виглядывает в окно, ходять люди і тут у нього виявляється ще легкі галлюцинації, і він бачить, що люди піднімають в глаза на нього, і він думає, вони вже все знають, вони вже тут, вони прийшли за
мною.
Він починає закрывати різні камери на ноутбуці, телефони, виключає зв'язку, лазить в розетки для того, щоб посмірити в жучков, закрыває двері, заходить мама, приносить їм покажуть суп, він сводить на
маму, а для нього відчувається, що це странно вигляє, а можливо, вони її подговорили, а можливо, це не мама, можливо, це хто-то приняло її внешність, а можливо, в цьому супі знаходиться хімічна каст
рація.
Ну і в тому, що проходит де-то недели три, і біонок берет такси в столицу, і там у нього вже берет на самоліт, і він вже хоче улететь в іншу стану, тому що він боїться того, що все тут вже все знають
і все хочуть його химически кастрювати.
І коли він приїхав, він перепутав в ріме і опознал на самоліт, тому його вдалося поймати. І коли його привезли вже к психіатру, то він прийшов, сказав, я знаю, що ця больниця була підстроена за п'ять
минутів з того, я приїхав, спеціально під мене. І насправді не врачи, ми переоденіся, ви спецслужба, ви пытаєтеся мене насправді наказати.
Що може зробити в цьому в цьому віде? Я не знаю. Є чітке убеждення, логика не работает. Саме худше, що можна зробити, зробитися чого відео переубедити. Його можна відео відео обманувати, то есть вход
ити в сьому в союзі, підкрепити його відео убеждення, що я знаю, що вони там в округі рідом, але ми зберімося. Але це продержиться, можливо, час на цьому, якщо він сильно вибухований, а потім знову
доверіюється.
І тут тільки медикаментами можна це робити, а дати те кількість медикаментів, які необхідні в Європі, це задача психіатра, соціальні служби і так далі, там, чуть-чуть краще це развито, в плані соці
альних служб, підтримки, середнього медицинського персонала, які з цим роботи, психологи, які там проведують, т.е. це ця задача.
А в Україні це стаціонар.
Пожизненно вже, да?
Нет, тут тож бувають реніси длинні.
Тобто цей парень може вийти в нормальне, коли він буде нормально себе чувствувати і жити без цих мыслей?
Да, але він, скоріше, буде пожизненно піти таблетки.
Я думала, що якщо вони так заходять, то вже таке відбувалося, то це вже все.
Він буде другою, він буде необычний, він буде все рано чуть-чуть відпочатся, в ньому буде мишлений, мишлений немножко другое.
Приводить пример, для нас 2 плюс 2 – це рівно 4, а для більшої – 2 плюс 2 – це ананас, який за нами следит.
Немножко по-другому работает логика.
Це може як-то визуально відпочатся, але при цьому встановити соціальну активність трудовую можна.
Звісно, можна знати, що він себе не навредить, ні себе, ні людям, таблетки.
Так, він буде неагресивний. Часто пацієнти не такі агресивні, скажімо так, як все думають.
Вони можуть бути гурливими, можуть бути спурними, напурними,
і якщо їх там ловити, то вони можуть давати спротивнення.
Але якщо чоловік по характеру був неагресивний і не спосібен був напасть на чоловік,
то він навіть застояние психоза не наподів.
Ви таке порасказували, що це слухати страшно, мені плохо.
Какі должны бути нерви, щоб працювати психіатром?
Ко всьому чоловік привыкає.
Ми сьогодні почти про війну не говорили,
хоча я думаю, що кожен із вас прожив цясть війни,
хоча в 2022 році, я думаю, що все думали, що це конец світа буде.
але тим не мене ми говоримо про різні речі, всі привыкли. Чоловік такий одразу, я думаю, він буде короче.
Я не знаю, чому мене преследують такі діагнози якісь чи случаи, але це ж дівчина,
яка мене прийшла на п'ятьсесі. Поговорить о дочери. Доча совершила попутку суїцида в 13 лет дівчці.
Напилася таблеток, в общем, там було багато, видимо, активуваний уголь, все-все-все.
Она почала рвати, ну то есть как-то не очень продумано.
Много выпила, начала ее рвати, и в общем, они не обратились к доктору.
Опять же, это Германия, говорю, вы не обращались, она говорит, нет.
А почему? Она говорит, ну страшно тебе вообще, чтобы ребенка не забрали.
На що, як зараз, не ходить в школу, така часто в своїй кімнаті закривається, що я їй порекомендувала все ж пойти проконсультироватися з доктором.
Я ще помню 300 років назад, що це у Светланы Ісайенко теж проходило, що якщо є попытка суїцида, це депресія.
Я просто не знаю, як це у дітей, у взрослых я тоді помню, а як це у дітей?
просто сказати, що це демонстративно було, ні.
Це не демонстративна штука.
Ось там сама спряталась, закрілася.
Це що взагалі?
Може таке, що батьканок спробував,
і вона його не поведет к доктору,
і як-то воно саму ляжеться?
Воно ляжеться, може бути.
Можете бути?
Желательно все одно, конечно.
Це не та ситуація,
я вам щас розкажу так коротко про три вида суицида, то есть вот вы щас говорите про демонстративный, істинный, ну і ще третий вид суицида, давайте вот разберемо, че разница, быстренько, да, я понимаю
, в чей вопроса есть, демонстративно-шантажний вид суицида, это когда человек, вообще пламотно у него нету себя убить, а он манипулирует своим здоровьем для того,
можна получити вигоду, то есть вигода — это либо внимание, привезти її внимание,
що «помогите, посмотрите, насколько мне плохо».
Второе — це наказати человека, научити його так не делать.
Например, мальчик, давайте так, девочка пообщалась с каким-то своим другом мальчиком,
мальчик порезав себе вену, щоб показати, що якщо ти можеш так робити, то я себе вигляю, то я себе вигляю.
Часто більше подросткового возрасту, либо определенный тип личності
Такий манипулятивний.
Вероятність того, що чоловік умрє, є в случае,
якщо чоловік, він це робить, скажімо так, необдуманно,
але все ж пітається себе навредити, якось так, в перший раз.
Ніхто не знає, як це робить правильно.
Якщо це може таки висказуватися, правильно себе навредити.
Ну, напрямер, дівчина зашла в ванну, заблакала,
з того, щоб ставитися молодим чоловіком, взяла нож, порезала себе вену,
вышла показати ему, що я себе порезала вену старе, як сказати, що ти мене довів, а він вже уйшов.
Вона співлась, посмотріла на руки, кров тече, вона теряє сознання, і все, ніхто не вызыває скорого допомогу, ніхто не зашиває, і нічого не відбувається.
Це може привести до світельного ісходу.
Але це, якщо не повезе, скажімо так, це 2% на 98%, в 98% случая, що людина виживає, а в 2% може произведення, що-то виживає.
Второй вариант – це істинний суїцид. Тут 2% то, що людина виживає, і 98% то, що не виживає.
К цьому виду суїцида можна применити таку фразу, вона не дуже корректно звучит, але так, це по буту, скажімо так.
Суїцидники вивають тільки мєд, а остальні – це те, з ким можна работать.
Настоящий суїцид, істинний,
який при тяжелом психістичному заболеванні,
в якій-то депресії,
коли все продумано,
це той самий суїцид,
коли людина виходить з депресії,
починає улыбатися,
і через три дня він умирає,
тому що він вже приймав рішення,
йому стало легче.
Це те суїциди...
Я вам приведу теж один пример з практики.
Мужчина, 35 років,
успішний бізнесмен,
Дом загородний, двохэтажний, машина, двох дітей, жена. Американская мечта, все замечательно. В итоге, в течении последних четырех месяцев стал менее активным, стал более пассивным, больше лежит,
меньше разговариваясь с людьми, постоянно начал вздыхать, отказывался от каких-то вещей, которые ему приносили удовольствие.
Я в 5 часу утром просыпался, смотрел потолок, ходил, ходил, ходил по дому, постоянно сказав, какая разница, в чому смысл і так далі.
Ну, ніхто на це внимание не обращався, говорить, що то можна і психологу сходить.
Ну, і, в принципі, на цьому все рекомендації заканчивались.
За неделю до попадання в поле зрення, скажімо так, медицинських работників, он стал лучше.
Появилась бодрость, у нього появилась активність,
начал улыбаться і предложив жені і детям проведати жену Маку,
которая живет полчаса от їх дому.
Он їх провожає, дает їм вещи, машину сажає, провожає туда, улыбається, машет рукой.
Заходить домой, поднимається на горячий чердак,
на чердак, де в ньому лежит банкерс, де в ньому лежит веревка, де в ньому написані записки.
Він піднімається туди, дзвонить своєму лучшему другу і говорить, прийдіть, пожалуйста, ко мене.
Нічого не могло объяснить, прийдіть, зними мене, щоб у мене, мої родственники не виділи мене вісящими.
І владе трубку. Друг жил в пяти минутах, а когда друг приєкав, він вже був мрот.
Т.е. він придумав все. Т.е. він думав вже в останніх кілька місяців.
Т.е. тут, скоріше згодо було бути чудо, щоб він вжив.
Не знаю, веревка порвалась внезапно, хоча тисячі разів вже її прорвав, щоб не порвалась.
Але вдруг вона порвалась, він упав, ударився головою, потеряв сознання і приїхав, його підняв і увез.
Тогда да, але якщо ця веревка порветься, він упаде і не потеряє знання, він повесить стену ще й виробку.
Тобто це називається істинний суїцид, найстарший.
І останній від суїцида, третій, той, який ми говорили, називається аффективний.
Которий непродуманий, але з цією себе вбити.
Він визникає на піці негативних емоцій.
Коли людина, якщо у нього порветься веревка, він не поїздить в 2 раз.
тому що він вже випугається, воно вже вийде, т.е. це вже вийде.
І це часто у дітей, їм тяжелі регулирують свої емоції,
особливо в подростковому візраці, коли є гормональні змінення,
і тоді в цей момент, типу, вона пошла гулять не зі мною, а з іншими дівочками,
значить я їй не потрібна, а може я взагалі нікому не потрібна,
а може їй жити не потрібно, а пошли ви себе чертові матері,
і зараз я покажу, що ви все потім плакали і жаліли об цьому, і напивається таблетка.
Какі таблетки, вона не читала, вона просто схватила, в слізах не видела, даже з цими слезами хватало таблетки, щоб набросати этим активуванням угля. І потім, коли вона прийшла в себя, звісно, вона
вже не повторилає. Це аффективний тип суїцида, не повторилає.
Але подібне ситуації можуть бути також. Повторяювшіся аффективні суїциди можуть бути при попыткому суїциду, можуть бути при пограничному растрійстві річні. Це дуже серйозне растрійство, яке займає
дуже багато процент, скажімо так, пацієнтів, які обращаються, попадають в полі зрения психіатра.
Тому що у них перманентне желання умереть, у них дуже сильний пік перепадів настроєння, і для них характерні самоповреження, селф-харм,
які вони використовують для того, щоб убирати напрямі емоційну і приключитися на біль.
Але вони постійно думають, що у них це працює так.
Увидел пуговицу, эта пуговица була на пальто у якого-то мужчины,
этот мужчина с ней більше не общается, потому что никому она не нужна,
в принципі, і зачем вообще мне не жить на этой планете?
І падає глупо-глупо в дисфорію, таке тяжеле, таке психічно-эмоційне состояние,
з якого відбереться, що ніколи не вибереться, хоча вона випала за п'ять минут.
Человек може в слезах слово так вот щелкать эти таблетки з блистера,
Набрать жменью, поставити жмень для большого гелу, то есть у него уже настроение приключилось.
Поэтому называется эмоционально-лабильно, еще как таково называется, быстрое перепадное настроение.
Вот это вот аффективно.
То есть в этом случае с девочкой, о которой я сказала, здесь нужно провести дифференциальну диагностику между тем,
что это просто эпизод аффективный на фоне подросткового возраста гормональних дезрегуляций,
Либо це вже паттерн пограничного росту, але і 100 років не поставити, тому що це ставиться з 18 років.
Але треба поставити на ті інші.
Скажіть, будь ласка, Юлечка, я по цій ж темі хочу.
Вовремя ковида дуже багато було суицидників, дуже багато.
Це з-за прививки, як ви думаєте, це з-за прививки, чи це якась побачка ковида?
Ковід – це нейротропний вірус, який поражає нервну систему.
Було багато людей, які...
Особенно...
Це було чітко видно, по крайні мере, в моїй практиці.
Ви говорите, що багато суїцидів було, ви це заметили.
А я заметив, по мужчинам, у котрих розвивалися тревожні расстройства.
Лет 45, панічні атаки, лет 45.
Котори, вони, естественно, не вакцинировалися,
Але вони пережили ковид, переболіли ковидом, і потім приходили, і такі офігавши, вони навіть не знали слова тривога. Музик работав там, не знаю, де-то механиком, і таке, якого-то відчування непонят
ного в серця. Ну, також, стремно. Я не знаю, що це таке.
Тобто він ніколи не задавався тему ментального здоров'я, і ніколи б не задавався, як б не ковид.
Тому ковид ассоційовані расстройства существують, правда.
Вони запускають, як він може бути тим триггером, який запустит ця заболію.
Як, наприклад, може запустити даже шизофріну, як було з цією, який я розказував,
де триггером стала ссылка на контент неприємливого.
От може бути вмісті вірус ковід,
який неправильно повіддістував на нервну ткані.
Я закінчу, минути.
Зараз, після сесії, вона прийшла на наступну сесію,
вона поговорила з дочерю, сказала,
може, це у тебе депресія, може, сходимо к діктору.
І вона согласилась.
Вони пошли к психіатру, но тут же, в Германії.
Вони поговорили з нею, роскоязічного нікого не було.
Ну так, що-то розуміли, що-то не розуміли.
Говорить, ти хочеш, можеш залишатися в больниці, хочеш їдь дому.
Ти обіцяєш, що ти нічого з собою не зробиш?
Вона говорит, да, я обіцяю.
До следующего, через три недели, следующий у них визит.
Вот так практикують здесь.
Не знаю, як у нас з цим.
У нас є одне роздіщення, яке я заметила в общині, скажімо так,
і з пацієнтами, і з колегами з Європи.
В советській школі театрії ми, в першу чергу, не віримо пацієнту, на слово.
Тобто ми пітаємося це невербально зрозуміти, то є вірт він, чи не вірт, і підказати, що буде далі.
І він говорить, що в мене все нормально, все в мене отлично.
Але я не вірю, я все ж зверно сделаю так, як я думаю, що вірше я покажусь дироком, ніж він суїцидів.
Тобто в Європі значально чоловіку вірят.
То есть я вас спрашиваю чітко, протокол, ты хочеш зробити це зробити? Не хочу. До свидання. Все, ну то есть это правда.
Вот, но опять же, скорее всего, вот то, что описывает, вы описывали по поводу этого ребенка, ну у нее явно проблеми в немецкой школе, она не може на какие-то все нормальні у друзей, там у какие-то
все иностранцы, она чувствует себя.
Компания. Хорошо все було. Компания в останнє час, останні півгода з іншими дівчинками такими непутєвими стала гулять і стало все ухудшаться.
Я більше сталкиваюсь з тим, що не можуть себе дітям натичуватись, не можуть адаптируватися до нової середії, хочуть в Україну, а в Україні вже теж нікого немає, все раз'їхалися, одноклассники, грубо
говоря, і діти чувствують себя такими потерянними.
Тому, так, скорей, може бути таке, либо возрастно, либо вопросы більше пограничному маторюю.
Благодарю вас.
Так, Анастасія, пожалуйста.
Я повернула. Пользуясь случаем, пользовалась случаем.
Скажите, пожалуйста, я занимаюсь сама в сессиях постоянно с КПТ.
Але вже на протяжі 4-5 років, ще навчання війни, такий спектр емоцій як-то притушився, знаєте.
Ну, суета-сует, життя, потім полномасштабна, і ще більше активувалися, потім расслабилися, потім зоксуційний кризис в тому году плюс діагноз.
І сказати, я проходила тесты на депресію, депресії немає, але вже давно нічого не радує, взагалі нічого не радує.
ну вот но в то же время когда там диагноз рак был поставлен три операции то тоже кипиша не
было все пропало я умру там то что это как блокировка каких-то эмоций наверное не туда
при этом я могу повеселиться с друзьями посмеяться но все равно какая-то внутри
такая пустота есть грубо ну могу искусству не то что мы искусно насильно нет я могу в моменте
там повеселить даже защитная реакция у меня на любой стресс и любо это такой смех оптимизм мой
все прорвемся а вот но нет вот этих ярких машину купил машина какая-то квартира там ну там затопила
дочери квартира в ну и вот какая-то она нет это уже старость все или это все-таки влияние еще
ще активна, плюс кризис інсексуальний,
плюс мене медицинское ввели в менопаузу,
у меня гормональний, да, там,
причем гормонотерапия не назначена,
потому что, ну, диагноз рад,
то есть такие поддерживающие БАДы, да, там,
качает свое, вот это вот, хочу, не буду,
плюс СДВГ, и вот, если прийти к психіатру,
есть что-то такое, чтобы больше, ну, так,
поднять по шкале, поднять,
ну, как-то оно так ровно идет, знаете,
ну, ровно, вкус какой-то такой, нет вкуса,
Іскусно ввели венопалу?
Ну, медицину, операции удалили.
А, операции.
А, операции сначала, да, шейка потом, это потом хоро, все полностью, да.
Ну, то, что вы описываете, напоминает такой симптом, который называется ангедвания, да?
То есть, нескоряє, не апатія.
Апатія – це якраз є слово апатія в народі, що означає.
Апатія, якщо говорити простим різком, то нічого не хочеться, апатія.
Але якщо говорити позитивні апатії, то це відсутствие всіх емоцій.
Не просто так, що ви можете писати, а я, чесною, нічого не відчуваю.
А вот я вам приведу пример. У мене був пацієнт, у нього вже простая форма шизофрії.
Апатика, апатичний синдром. Уже немає ралюцінації, вже немає рідових ідеї, от він вже йшов в дефект.
От він сидит на кресле, я був студентом, підходив до нього, кажучи, що хочеться? Добой.
А зачем? Ти не знаю. Що ти там будеш робити? Ти нічого не будеш робити.
Що ти щас робиш? Ну щас сижу на кровати. Чем хочеться щас займатися? Пойду покурю.
вже більше потім бачить на кровати на весьвод вот это вот то есть тут вы хоть нюрба описувати
такие вещи которые купили купила машину не радую покупка машины не радую то есть у вас
было какое-то внутреннее желание купить путешествие еду но так чтобы нет то есть
Це якась така, я така, ну, ну, є, ну, ні, тож нормально.
Ну, це ангідонія, це депресивна симптома депресії, не обязательно, що раз депресія?
Так, я тест проходила, я тест проходила, і он, значит, там шкала субдепресії.
Ну, короче, субдепресія, ну, вот, как раз не все симптомы депресії появились,
Некоторі депресивні симптоми. Т.е. субдепресія – це вже не норма. Це верхня, точні, нижня граніці норма, яка вже входит в біже депресія. Т.е. субдепресія – це тож м'який. І там просто проявляється не
все симптоми.
немає суїцидальних тенденцій і мислях, немає чувства вины, немає проблем з сном, можливо.
Але це ангідонія, слово «гідонія» — це вдовольство, філософія,
яка продовігає постійно, а це «ам» — відсутствие, відсутствие удовольствия.
Тому негатив описує, що депресія в якій степені хуже, ніж онкологія.
Я знаю, що це по-разному можна інтерпретувати, саме зв'язано з онкологією в ній степені.
Тому це мнення я зараз озвучу. Человек з онкологією хоче жити, хоче наслаждаться і ценив момент.
Человек з депресією не може получити взагалі ніякого удовольстві в тяжелій депресії,
і тому він не бить цінності життя, і для нього життя просто зуществування.
Нет, життя я люблю при цьому, дуже-очень люблю.
Я люблю общення, я люблю встречи.
Вот просто радости такой, знаєте, як осадок, ну, таке блаженство.
Є таке спокійство стало, хотя через полгода після операции
первая разблокировка була как раз стадія горя.
Я там рыдала неделю, я просто неделю не могла остановиться.
Я просто рідала, рідала, хоронила всі свої прожиті.
Можливо, коли-то мені сложилось таке впечатнення, що я заблокувала емоції,
тому що все те горе, яке проживала в течінні життя,
оно так ярко не виражалось.
Тобто хоронення близьких, то есть все ці горішні события, вони були заблокувані.
Я так не рідала, як за цю неделю, грубо кажучи,
роботи з терапевтом і все остальне.
Говорю, і діагноз поставили, сказали,
ну, хорошо, пайдем, зробимо оператию.
Ну, могу не вийти з оператию, могу умереть.
Ну, факт.
Могу. То есть, нет таких вот, ну,
как это, красивых, ярких эмоций, да?
І мені кажучи, це блокування була в своє час,
тому і потери, така все, в серість прошло.
Ну, це більш така психотерапіччя інтерпітація, знаєте,
тут скільки психіатрів.
Я кажу, да, да. Нет, у меня, бывает, злость поднимається, да, но вот это его трава.
Ну, це не, совершенно не виключає цю теорію, да, т.е. імеє місто бути, заблокування емоцій, да, це імеє місто бути.
Да, це моя інтепутація, да.
Але, зість, можливо, для того, щоб іспытувати сильне горе, тож необхідні бачити ті ж саме мере медіатори, щоб іспытувати сильну радість.
І то, і то определенний стрес для этого.
І, можливо, ви використовували все, що було накоплено, для того, щоб спитати негатив,
а далі все стало, якщо в простому жаку, все стало пресною, грубо говоря,
щоб спитати негативні емоції.
Якщо питати ваш конічний, як я розумію, якщо зробитися до спеціалісту моєго профіля,
то може я вам щось продовжити.
Є такі таблетки, які будуть не уменьшати негатив, а чуть повішати позитив.
Це таблетки ще більш легкі, якщо ви...
Є випадок сертраліна, циталопрама, антипесанты.
Це теж антипесанты, але вони атипичні.
Не влияють на серотонин.
Вони дають дофаминту і нарадрінаріну.
А при цьому повышений кортизол.
Понятно, що тут треба работать.
Ну плюс гормональний.
Хоча вже год пройшов, мене вже не так качає гормонально.
Хоча мене дуже качало.
то, конечно, там нарушений сон, приливы, отливы, холодно, жарко, все это я проходила, там, все круги до этого, очень активно.
Дисоняться, да?
Конечно, или не можеш заснуть, или не можеш, ну, да, или рано просыпаєшся, или посереді ночі просыпаєшся, два часа работаєш, потому що разликаєшся, как-то, да, это все було.
Я думаю, может, это на фоне гормон вообще блокировка, хотя я же…
Це може бути, я не можу сказати, що є чітка причина, це може бути совокупність факторів і так далі. Тут, скоріше, можна ли з цим робити? Можна.
Так, короче, хочеться вернути, ви знаєте, як от, у мене ярко-голубі глаза, вони, мені кажучи, чістю, сері, і хочеться чуть-чуть голубізни вернути в глаза, щоб як-то дивитися поярче.
А зараз, як ви знаєте, стара бабка вже вік прожила, типо вже ніхто нічого не дивляє, радости такої нет, ну машина і машина.
Ну, то есть, вот, как-то, я же говорю, нет радости. Ну, путешествия, пути же, ну, хорошо, преисполнена спокойствием, дзен какой-то, и почему-то у меня все равно складывается впечатление, что я не
пришла к покою, а я пришла к тонкому такому пофигизму, то есть, вообще, чтобы, наверное, не испытывать таких каких-то эмоций.
Дякую за перегляд.
якимось в подростковому визраці, такі сильні, хочеться радуватися, хочеться...
Ну це скоріше часто побочний эффект в некоторых підписанках,
такий допомінний компонент, у когось це саме эффект.
Ну то есть з цим можна работать. Дякую за разом це можна за разом
убрать, може це і со времені само пройдуть, тож скоріше пройдуть.
Але часто це можна і побыстріше подібрати.
Я заинтересований, хорошо. К нему привыканий нет. Я правильно варююваю? Це не наркота. Я вкорнулася.
Не, є щось з привыканням, є щось у нас є акаріювати. Приходить.
Я тебя вилечу, да. Я поняла. Ну, то есть, с этим тоже работает психіатр.
Ну, психотерапевт, естественно, в первую очередь.
Ну, психотерапевт, да, он же мене не отправил к психіатру. Я работаю дальше с психотерапевтом, КПТ.
Все, ми пройшли не раз, проходимо цей интерес.
Але я теж умею це дуже добре обманувати, тому...
Тобто...
Хорошо.
Картина смазана.
В общем, к тому, якщо придет такий теж клиент, де счастье, то теж можна відправити.
Да, у нас як нехватка хорошого, так і слишком багато плохого.
то есть психіатр, в принципі, с не такими емоциями, які хотілося б работать,
афективне расстройство і тревожне, не говоримо вже про людину, там всякі.
Харашо, відповідальність, якщо не зміни, якщо ти живеш в цьому годі,
більше года, два року, то якщо полгода вже надійти, тому що це вже затіжна і може зайти в депресію.
Ну, я б даду фору в вашому випадку, тому що гормони дуже сильно пов'яють на емоційність.
Навіть, возьмемо те же саме арадні корцептиви, які я использую, вони дуже сильно можуть пов'яють на тревожність, і на емоційність, і так далі.
Я б ще немшо подождав, якщо отойдуть, скажімо так, гормональність стабилизується, а я от этого считав полгодика ще.
Спасибо.
Ну, і, якщо хочете, може зараз, але якщо хочете так, то може. Подождати ще може.
Так, смотрите, тут вопрос задавая Карась, Татьяна.
Дякую за перегляд!
Татьяна, ви задали питання? Можете озвучити. Я його зрозуміла, але можете озвучити.
А зараз, смотрите, було таке один раз замечання від моєго супруга о тому, що ти не думаєш, що у тебе є роздвоєння річності, якби ти вот со мною по одному ведєш, а вот з іншими людьми ведєш якось по-д
ругому.
Вот вчера ти мені одно сказав, а сегодня що-то ти якось по-другому сказав. Я це не отслеживаю, для мене нормально.
Але цей вопрос мене вже два роки мучить.
Чому він не задавав його таке?
І я б хотіла знайти побільше, що знайти від розтроєння личності?
Дякую.
Дякую за питання.
Мужчинам складно зрозумінити змінчість жінки.
Вони не можуть зрозумінити.
Мнення може бути змінюватися.
Для них вже така татологія.
Це називається емоційна логість.
коли менеється быстре настроєння, чи мнення минується.
По поводу роздроєння лічності.
Це називається диссоціативне роздройство ідентичності лічності.
Це крайне рідке заболевання, яке я не бачив.
Ви практики, мої колеги, скоріше, теж не бачили.
Це процент, якесь соту, тисячну, мільйонну проценту тільки проявляється.
Але на практиці, ну в теорії це проявляється так.
Це поломаний механізм захисту психіки.
Тобто, буду щас говорити неприятні речі, чувствітельні з грудь і ушки.
Ребінок, маленький, дівчина, пусть буде мальчик, дівчина.
Подвергається сексуальному насилию со сторони своєго родителя.
Тобто навіть неадекватно сильний стрій какой-то.
Происходит конфлікт в невероятній голові,
тому що мені роблять самим близьким мене чоловік.
Тобто я не понимаю нього.
В цей момент психіка пытається знайти
якийсь механізм для захисты.
Хоча якось, тому що є, наприклад,
такий механізм захисты, як витіснення.
Чоловік забувається якісь травматичні события в своїй житті.
постфактум.
А є
диссоція лічності,
т.е. визначається ця лічності
і виявляється
другое, яка прийняє
ця травматичній опути.
І потім
чоловік
починає
запомінає, як це працює.
І в цей раз, коли чоловіку буде
плахо, він як щіт
виставить цю лічності вмісті себе.
І тому ці дві річності мають разний опит, тому що річність, яка була значальною, сублічність, так звичайно,
вона не помнит травматічних событий, а річність, яка зублічність, яка відбувається вовремя травмі, не помнит хороших событий.
Тому у них разна пам'ять, у них разний, по-разному характер може розвиватися.
І ось так іде не ращеплення, а ращеплення одне, а ращеплення одне, а ращеплення дополнительного, т.е. дві полноценні личності.
І особливість в тому, що це дійсно дві полноценні личності в одному телі.
Которе, вони можуть навіть не знати відсуществування другого.
Просто включаться раз в сутки, грубо кажучи.
Одна включається і не розуміється.
Думала, що вона спала, наприклад, і просто ходить.
друге обмічається. І в терапії, інтересний підход, їх потрібно познакомити, подружити друг с другом, да, і научити взаємодійствувати
вместе. Тобто, це навіть, скоріше, не буде лічитися, вони будуть розвиватися параллельно. Тобто, це такий прям феномен.
Дякую за перегляд, що є однеяйцеві близніці, є однеяйцеві близніці. Однеяйцеві близніці – це коли в одну яйцеклетку виходять два сперматозолі. І з одной яйцеклетки розостається дві одинакові зовсім
личності. Два одинакового чоловіка рождається.
Потрібно, вони получають різний опыти, тому вони можуть відчуватися по характеру, їх можуть відчувати, у них різні і так далі.
Тут то ж саме, тільки це відбувається вже не з точки зрення яйцеклетки зіготы, гомет, а з точки зрення психіки, розділилися і все, одна включається, другая включається.
Тобто, що показується в фільмах по типу спліта, це концептуально похоже.
Тому те, що Ви описали, Тетяна, це не роздайдення вичності.
Дякую.
Так, Ліна, будь ласка.
Я постараюсь дуже коротко. Дякую, що даєте можливість ще.
Ну, по-перше, подякувати Вам, що Ви настільки обширно розкриваєте кожне з наших питань,
питань, тому що ви вже відповіли дуже багато на тих питань, які були десь там в мене за кадром. Ну, власне, дуже дякую.
Таке я вже тоді своє питання докручу. Значить, естетелопрам, скільки там, 6 років, але з перервами, тобто це вагітність,
годування, близько трьох років перерви, потім був, боже, щось таке, від чого поправляються, я забула, як він називається, не столь важно.
Він мені не підійшов, я себе погано почувала. І зараз уже рік, венлофоксин, 150-ка. Я таке зрозуміла, що межовий присутній однозначно. Це перше. Друге, тривожний стан, реально я себе без нього не пам
'ятаю.
На венилфоксині, пролонгованої дії, я вже точно півроку, ясно, що така природня тривога, така, як має бути, вона є, але от є її патогенною, яка прям постійно, її вже немає.
Але при цьому я пам'ятаю ще з дитинства, себе з тривогою, тобто це прям мій такий нормальний стан.
Більше того, генетично, я так розумію, що якісь всякі класні діагнози мені передалися, бо я недавно познайомилась з біологічним батьком, мама його лишила в 10 місяців самого і він чуть не загинув,
він теж сидить роками на сертраліні, військовий, зараз ще в нього куча контузій і теж дуже цікава особистість.
Питання моє полягає в тому, якщо я спочатку казала, що хочу дуже здійти з антидепресантів, я розумію, що можливо це робити не варто і чи взагалі буває так, що людина все життя просто на антидепресант
ах, якщо плюс-мінус себе нормально почуває. Які плюси і мінуси? Дуже дякую.
Мінуси, побільші ефекти на зені пресентів, це найголовніший мінус, особливо вплив на лібідо, на апетит, вплив на яскраві дебільність на війні,
і потім важко зарадувати, менше позитивних емоцій може бути, навіть деякі випадки, більш зладження, відчуття рівності.
Я не впевнений, що для кожного можна знайти антидепресант, який не буде мати ефектів.
Мені здається, неможливо для кожного, але для багатьох можна знайти, який можна пити, яких в очах не було.
Знаєте, деякі пацієнти кажуть, що хочеться вже пристати пити препарат через три місяці, я кажу, які побічні ефекти, можливо ліпідо.
Хто не знає, то важко на антидепресанті отримати оргазм, як хлопчика, так і дівчата.
І з лібіду, і з снами, тобто все в точку, це все присутнє, але якщо порівнювати зі станом, який був раніше, то це квіточки.
Ну, і якщо, наприклад, навіть говорити про, нехай там з апетитом, ну, в принципі, можна боротися.
Чи є, наприклад, ті самі препарати для лібіду? Тобто приймати антидепресанти і тут робити корекцію.
Так, деякі є варіанти, що можна спробувати, це не обов'язково я запрацюю, але варіанти завжди.
Тобто змінилися, це побічні проєкти, які ніяк не шкодять людині, скажімо так.
Тобто немає такого, що вона попила антидепресанти, 15 років захворіла чимось, ні, так не буває.
Просто, як і життя може підвищуватись, але в чомусь, що-то даємо, що-то забираємо.
на жаль бо є деякі антидепресанти які не можна довго приймати от прям категорично небажано є такий
наприклад антидепресант який називається амитріптілін це приблизно той антидепресант який що ви
собі являєте коли чуєте слово антидепресант тому що він дуже старий він дуже седативний він
дуже дає вагу і він впливає на перистальті кишківника Я в мене були такі випадки коли
людина приймала 15 років цей препарат і із-за постійної хронічної закрити видали кишківник
людині тому що ну були яку покажуть чи там кава енексикація і так далі ось тому ну там є вплив на
серце негативне тобто є вплив на вагу негативне тут бажано чим швидше тим краще або переключитися
на щось інше на більш лайтовий препарат або просто з нього краще зійти але сучасні антиперсанти це
взагалі інша історія той же самий есцеталопрам там виключно якщо от уявити аметритилін це така
зв'язка ключей там кожен ключ не підходить до якихось рецепторів так їх там штук 15 то есцеталопрам
це виключно один ключик який впливає тільки на сертоніон транспортер все більше нічого
багато впливати на організм серотонін в принципі особливо не можу, він дуже безпечний і багато людей, є досвід, це в нас, в нашій країні почали пізно приймати, скажімо так, антидепресанти,
Тому що була якась дегматізація, не буду нікому казати,
а вдруг мене заберуть, а вдруг мене залічат.
А наприклад, в Ізраїлі почали з 60-50-х років пити антидепресанти,
і є люди, які досі п'ють, і почали, і п'ють, і п'ють, і нічим вони не гірші.
Тобто, поки у нас пили водку, там пили антидепресанти.
Ті, хто пили водку, у нас плану закінчили, а хто пили антидепресанти,
в Ізраїлі нормально. Це як приклад.
є інші країни просто я чув звідки чомусь дуже багато історій є люди які просто там приходять пацієнти
спустя декілька там років часи до чоловіки вони любять чомусь приймати антелесанти довго деякі до речі там приходять
я приймаю мені подобається там вже 10 років просто вирішив запитати чи можна мені народжувати там дітей на цих антелесантах
що ми щорокі за це хвилюється можна і все нормально нормальний
він в принципі нормальний тільки там є також плив там на шлунок і на інколи
це не дуже добре інколи нема побочок не підійшов найкраще забрав всю симптоматку практично я думаю
що найближчі років 5-10 будуть з'являтися з меншою діякістю побочок наприклад зараз з'явився
це препарат який називається брінтелікс він 2013 року вийшов він зараз спорний тому що він слабенький
набагато слабший в нього є побічний факт нудота який може дуже довго не проходити
але він вже не впливає на лібіда він вже не впливає на апетит він вже не впливає на сон
Його можна приймати в будь-який момент протягом дня і його можна кинути без сімдрома відділу, вже трошки інший механізм відділу.
І зараз в цю сторону йдуть розробки. Знову ж таки, не призвав дійстою, просто самолічення не підтримує.
Як мінімум, відчуваю себе в безпеці, дякую.
Якщо казати про межовий розлад, він має таку властивість як вигоране.
Межовий розлад закінчується в якийсь момент і людина повністю адаптується.
Тобто її емоції зазрівають до кінця, і людина стає менш емоційною, і їй стає легше.
І це найкраще, якщо так можна сказати, із роздобу способистості.
І він має дійсно класний прогноз.
Він дуже важко проживається, але в витогі прогноз нормальний.
Найстарша людина з межоблазоном, яку ви зустрічав, який ще скаржився на свої скарти, це було 45.
Ну і завдяки живому розвитку людина стала дуже творчою, відомою і так далі, але вона старша.
І вже поступово перестала про це говорити і так далі, втрачається актуальність і втрачаються ці симптоми, які навчаються.
Ну і люди відмовляються від антидепресантів.
Так, добре, дякую. Кристина, будь ласка.
Здравствуйте, у меня вопрос про пограничное расстройство. В курсе його не було, і я когда-то слышала, що пограничное расстройство крайне тяжело діагностирується, і для психологов і коучів це самі так
і тяжелі клієнти.
Есть ли какие-то маркери, які ви нам зараз можете сказати, щоб можна було підтримувати?
Некоторі симптоматики розповідаються. Достатньо ярко.
Во-первых, це має бути чоловік 18 років.
Це має бути починатися в подростковому визраці.
Тобто от 13 років до 13 років.
В подростковому визраці, коли це дебітировало,
має бути бути не дуже благоприєнна обстановка в соціумах,
в яких знаходився білянок в той час.
Т.е. це либо в семьі, либо в школі.
Т.е. це либо непринятие буллінг какой-то дуже сильний,
либо это должны бути проблеми с холодной матерью,
яка віхала на заробітну, куда-то бросилася,
з бабушкой, білянок не взаємодействував,
т.е. не почувствував, не понимав,
чому відказався не у близьких, близьких чоловік.
Постоянно він знаходився в системі опасності.
Отец чи мать – алкоголик, агресивний і так далі.
І тому немножко порушується регуляція емоцій.
Тобто це ставиться після 18 років.
Характерні проявлення.
Перше – це пістоянний страх покинутості.
Чоловіку дуже страшно, що від нього всі відкажуться.
Почему так происходит?
Потому что это был даже такой эксперимент,
когда человеку показывают фотографии нейтральных, скажем так, лиц,
і человек говорит, ну, це нейтральне лице, ну, не знаю.
Ну, як ви з мене считаєте, сітаєтеся, який я.
Ну, никакой. Пирожок с ничем, да, ви говорили, никакой.
Но если показать такое лицо человеку с органичностю в своїй личності,
Тобто він може динципінивати його як ухажающе і як то, який хоче обидити і побросити.
Тобто це відбувається на рівні первичного сканингу.
Тобто сказати чоловіку просто не накручивай, не получится, він не накручивает.
Він це значально так считывает.
Грубо говоря, якщо я буду так с вами розмовляючи, скажи, то ви себе накручуєте, я не злой.
Почему так думаєте, я не злой?
Ну то есть скажіть, я ж вижу, що збой.
І це той чоловік, коли я буду розмовляти обычно, він буде, я ж віжу, що ти злой, ти хочеш мене бросити, уйти.
І часто це підношується до якимось близьким людям, друзям, к родителям.
І от він постоянно в страхі того, що він когось потеряє.
А він боїться потеряє, тому що він сам по себе не може регулювати свої емоції.
Тому він постоянно хоче бути в компанії когось, тому що у нього з-за таких, то ли з-за генетичних, то ли з-за травматичного какогось опыта,
сформувалась внутрення регуляція емоцій, і тому йому потрібен внешний регулятор.
І в таких случаях часто люди подстраиваються под кого-то извне, для того, щоб його не бросили.
Можемо, може, датися бути якимось удобним, з кожним чоловіком посвоїватися.
Потрібний тип стратегії поведення іспользувати.
Їти люди, це перший момент, це найважніший, страх покинутості і це желание, неумение считывання емоцій. Дальше, імпульсивність, т.е. це використання психоактивних веществ, але це все следствиє. Психо
активні вещества для того, щоб стигулювати свої емоції, тому що самостійно я не можу. Дальше, сексуальне, необдуманне сексуальне поведення.
Чому? Тому що коли я с кем-то ряду, тому що я нужна, значить мене не бросят, тому що чаще то у жінці проявляється органічності строгічності, у мій теж, але є, але не діагностирується, тому що мусики
скоріше старчатся і з наркоманіються і йдуть в ріхаб, і вони будуть лічити наркоманію, тому що именно це інпульсивне использовання чого-то, що може заглушити, це є характерна черта цього заболівання.
Потім, з-за цих перипадок, відчування того, що близькі люди відказувалися, може бути зуицидальні мыси постійні, сплески агресії, аутоагресія для того, щоб вбрати ці сильні емоції, хоч як-то срегулюв
ати, не вмість чоловік саму регулювати, а благодаря тому, що він себе повідомив, він почав це регулювати.
І також, чому це називається пограничним різництвом, межовий розлад? Ранше считалось, що це на границі між неврозом і психозом, тому що ці пацієнти можуть бачити галлюцінації, у них може бути чув пар
анойи, але тільки в стресовій ситуації.
Вот, наприклад, у мене одна пацієнка, ті люди часто дуже творчі, і це не зовсім стереотип, але, тим не мене, ті люди будуть зеліними волосами пістоянно, тому що вони будуть постійно, у них неопродовж
енний образ себе, вони будуть постійно хочуть меніться, вони будуть постійно, у них настільки сильно багато емоцій, що вони вливаються на внішність.
У них буде татуировки, у них буде пирсинг. У них, скорее всего, да, то есть, они будуть необычно выглядеть для того, чтобы эти емоції как-то вылить куда-то.
Они, если будуть заниматься кимдотворчеством, это будет их, скорее всего, либо пишуть стихи для того, чтобы сублимировать, либо не рисую, чтобы сублимировать эти емоции.
И к чему это ввел, да. Вот одна девочка, она рисует, рисует, например, а, щас, я немножко забыла.
Девочка була пацанка, я художница, і она говорить, я вечером не вижу лиц людей, я вижу только черепа вместо лиц. І все ж таки, ой, шизофрения, ой, це ралюцінація, що там наде. А це у мене просто наст
ільки сильні емоції, що у мене появляться, ви проходили це, аффективні іллюзії.
Т.е. на фоне сильних емоций у них дорисовують свої, знаєте, у страха влазами, у них дорисовують какие-то моменты. Либо, наприкер, діти кажуть, що я видел, наприкер, человека, я сидя на дереві. Я сп
рашиваю, це що це? Це, ти поверила в це? Ти поверила в це? Ти не, я думаю, що це ралюцінація. А як можна поверити, що це ралюцінація? Тобто, якщо ти в це в це і вериш, то якщо це не настояще. Тобто,
як то вони це інтерпектирують.
Це називається пограничка. То ли психоз, то ли невроз. Так історично це відбувалося, так це назвали.
І тому, можливо, ви слухали інтересне соціальне об'язнення пограничного росту вічності.
Замечайно, не замечайно, є такі меми про те, що якщо ти прийшов в кофейню і у тебе бармен з татуїровками, з зеліними волосами,
з Пирсиною, то це буде найважливіше відео відео твоєї життя.
Звичайно.
Тому що, шкоріє всього, це пограничне розтворювання.
Чоловік себе так проявив, ну, це фенотипично так проявляється.
І, шкоріє всього, у нього дуже високий інтелект.
І, шкоріє всього, він дуже творчий.
І, шкоріє всього, він поступив в університет.
Але з-за того, що у нього постоянно менеється настроєння,
постоянно менеється желання, він його бачив на второму семістрі.
і потім бачив ще один і ще один, і він не получив до конца професії,
тому пішов на підробку в кофію.
І там чоловік, який, звісно, може бути яким-то невероятним художником,
зробив вам кофі, тому він буде самим вкусом.
Примерно так для себе об'ясню.
Супер, спасибо большое.
І вот ще один питання по поводу кофі.
Якщо я після кофі можу сладко-быстро уснути,
це що значить, що мене СДВГ?
Це залежить від типу нервной системи, чесно.
Тежно сказати.
Вообще, дивіться.
Кофі роботає так.
Він блокує рецептори усталости, грубо кажучи.
У нас є рецептори усталости.
Коли ми встаєм, к цим рецепторам присоединяються определені ключики.
Чим більше ключів, тим быстрі ми хочемо засипати.
Якщо ми п'ємо кофі, то ці замочки,
Которим ключики залишили і присоединиться, вони закриваються.
Але ми можемо випити кофі тоді, коли ключики вже вставлені.
І тому настоящее кофе для того, щоб збодритися.
Знаєте, як пивають правильно, еспресо.
Випивають кофі, потім ложаться спати на полчаса, просыпаються і потім не відправляється бодрость.
Тобто виходять ці ключики, воно заблокирується і потім чоловік бодреється.
Тому, якщо ви п'їли кофі і заснули, нічого не значить.
Я благодарю, спасибо більше.
Так, ще вопросик у нас є?
Вопросиків? Нет.
Спасибо вам огромное за дискуссию,
спасибо за такой живой интерес.
Як ви видите, я дуже люблю на такому розговарювати. Витальне здоров'я – це дуже важливо, це дуже круто і дуже круто, що все більше і більше людей присоединяється до цього движення, яке буде допомаг
ати.
Було дуже приємно з вами робити, дуже круті, складні питання, які, честно кажучи, на багато мене було дуже складно відповідати, не банальні, а реально дуже круті.
І, наверное, все-таки на нього я там попутався поболтати, позаниматися, як це називається, ризонерством, але так, будто я, наверное, до кінця не відповідав на нього, я тільки попутався.
Поэтому все в ваших руках. Изучайте, узнавайте і помогайте людям.
Вот. Всем пасіло большое за внимание. Всем пасіло.
Дякую за перегляд!